first new universe in over 25 years but
it's still a Bethesda RPG through and
through where you step into a new world
and you get that feeling of unlimited
possibilities
but this time it's not just one world
over a thousand worlds
because the choice of where to go it's
not ours it's yours
and it wasn't until now that we had the
technology to create it
from the rocks at your feet to the
mountains in the distance
to the people and creatures that live in
these worlds
that isn't just a backdrop that moon is
actually there orbiting the planet yes
you can visit it too
we realistically simulate the Galaxy
around you
our next Generation lighting model uses
real-time Global illumination to light
the world based on the type of star and
the makeup of the planet's atmosphere
[Music]
we also have an all-new animation system
and of course you can play it in third
person
and you can play it in first person
we love exploration and rewarding it but
you do explore differently in this game
given its scale
that usually involves exploring an area
you've landed in
you can collect resources
do a mission and maybe even stumble upon
something unexpected
I can't
we do love stuff and all of the items
allowing you to pick everything up and
you can view all that in your data menu
this is the hub for everything you're
doing from your skills to your ship your
missions and your inventory we love to
pack a ton of detail in every object
from all of your weapons
spacesuits
to food we just obsess over the details
and food we obsess over food
when you're done exploring you can walk
back or fast travel to your ship we have
Companions and crew you can take with
you I left vosco here back at my ship
welcome back Captain Howard and he can
even say your name let's head out
[Music]
our mission was to convey the Wonder and
Majesty of space exploration to evoke
the Romance of the golden age of early
space flight and we've been referring to
this approach as NASA Punk this means a
design language where the tech is
advanced yet still looks grounded and
relatable for us it's a contrast that's
where the visual interest is obviously
the NASA which is the rigid pod function
over style and then Punk which is all
about Style
you can see that visual style coming
through in your ship your ship is your
home for you and your crew and like many
of the spaces in our game it has a
slightly retro and analog touch a bit of
Lo-Fi rather than sci-fi where
everything is well used worn and lived
in alrighty what's the plan captain
this is your star map it starts with the
planet you're currently on
you can see all of its info and
resources you can choose a landing spot
or fast travel to known locations
backing out further you can view all the
planets in the system obviously the game
is big and it's here you can see planets
that have key locations missions or life
on them versus the many planets that are
Barren but resource heavy
zoom out even further to see all the
systems in this part of the Galaxy
here you can plot a course to ones that
are light years away this uses your
ship's grav drive to fold space and jump
to these systems and you will need to
upgrade your ship and skills if you want
to jump to the most distant ones but for
now we'll plot a course to the Alpha
Centauri system where we can find the
city of New Atlantis
foreign
course while we scan your ship's cargo
[Music]
scan complete
a cleared for landing at new Atlantis
[Music]
as soon as you land in a city like new
Atlantis your eyes are guided upwards to
just these boundless vast buildings
it's the biggest city we've ever made
not just in size but also in the amount
of custom art
crowds and quests
so the main focus when we're designing a
city is obviously what supports the
story we try and tell as many small
stories as possible this is a colony war
memorial it's a few moments of gameplay
that make the space feel like it's full
of real characters that are going about
their day-to-day lives it's paralyzed if
you really stop and think about it buddy
it's coffee it's also where your
adventure with constellation begins
[Music]
foreign
we have a lot to talk about by the time
you meet them constellation is sort of
seen as this mythical crew most people
don't even know they exist anymore
they're the last true explorers in the
galaxy and they're trying to find the
answers to some of Humanity's biggest
questions
so alien and I'm certain one of them
reached out and spoke to you
[Music]
the artifact if you could place it on
the table here
oh my God look at how it's coming
together that means
that means set built by an intelligence
outside the settled systems it's
definitely an Eclectic cast of
characters you've got Sarah Morgan the
ex-soldier in Adventurer now
constellations leader Mateo the
Theologian who believes that there's
definitely something else out there Noel
the gifted scientist in Sarah Morgan's
Protege and Walter a very successful
businessman in the settled systems and
constellations financier anything goes
as long as you have the money there's
also Vlad the ex-pirate Sam Coe the
former Space Cowboy and baron you know
what I hate about these Pirates
completely resistant to my otherwise
irresistible charm
the journey you take with constellation
is just the first that many you'll
embark on the settled systems is home to
all kinds of different stories people
and Adventures for you to uncover
[Music]
the United Colonies is where you'll find
new Atlantis the first major human
settlement in space
who live here value law discipline and
the legacy of humanity they consider
themselves the true children of Earth
you ever think of joining up with a
Vanguard of the United Colonies even get
your UC citizenship new Atlantis isn't
the only city within the United Colonies
the city of Sedonia on Mars to this day
serves as the largest Mining facility
for the United Colonies
beyond the United Colonies reach you
might find yourself in a much more wild
and independent Coalition of star
systems
[Music]
this is Freestar Collective space
capital of the Freestar Collective is
Aquila City
the stone route inn is an Aquila City
fixture
Ranger relies on judgment and intuition
to do what's best for the people
neon started out as a fishing platform
but is now known throughout the cell
systems as a pleasure City where almost
anything goes if you've got morality
issues this definitely isn't the job for
you
[Music]
reunion is hiring the best and brightest
of today for our future tomorrow
everyone has been chewed up and ground
up by Neon try not to get yourself
killed alright
outside the bounds of civilized space
there are still plenty of unclaimed
systems to explore but these areas are
also home to the most hostile factions
in the galaxy
the Great Serpent hungers all heathens
shall be made Dust In Time
a new face this is the face of a brave
Runner here to challenge the Red Mile
they think the Galaxy is theirs they are
wrong it belongs to the Crimson Fleet it
always has
[Music]
in Starfield we're pushing our cities
and settlements further than we ever
have before it's all there waiting for
you a slice of Humanity's future
so ready to get out there
[Music]
throughout the Galaxy there are so many
things to see and stories to experience
but the most important story is the one
that you tell
I'm the type of person who spends hours
in character creation and I think people
are going to be really excited when they
see all of the improvements we've made
one of the biggest overhauls was done
through our character generation system
we scanned a wide range of faces from
different age groups and ethnicities and
by mixing and matching out that data we
were able to create a highly detailed
and diverse characters
we use that exact system to create all
the characters and NPCs you're going to
see in the game so any character you see
almost always is a character you could
make yourself
hey come on come on okay take it easy
you were out cold uh no physical damage
mentally the jury's still out
you know who you are new recruit for
Argos extractors ring any bells
any of this look familiar
you start your character creation
Journey as though you're cycling through
employee records you'll pick from a
lineup of 40 presets and that'll be your
starting point
your journey from there can be as
detailed or as quick as you want it to
be this new system has more to offer
than ever before
it's also the simplest character
generation system we've ever had we let
the player get as close as possible to
make whatever they want with the various
facial morphs you can blend together the
thermostatic and makeup blemishes scars
piercings teeth settings it's a lot but
I think it's the most fun to use
character creation is more than just how
you look this is also where you start to
decide who you want to be that's where
backgrounds come in
backgrounds give you a bit of backstory
and starts you out with three basic
skills
from Chef to Dusty you know the crew
still has a betting pool about which
restaurant critic you must have crossed
to wind up here what's great about
backgrounds is you never know when yours
is going to come in handy you could be
in the middle of a fancy restaurant
talking to some guy and suddenly you
learn he needs a beast hunter to help
track down a monster fine I probably
should stick to professionals anyway
given what happened the last time we're
also giving you the option to customize
your build even further by letting you
pick up the three traits traits are
completely optional and they come with
their own advantages and disadvantages
your biggest fan
you'll join your crew and it'll give you
gifts if you're willing to put up with
this constant commentary I can't believe
I get to stand near you
my favorite trait is kid stuff you have
to pay some credits to support your
parents but they're very sweet and it's
really fun to go visit them honey we got
ourselves a visitor oh my God I came
across some hostile zealots in space but
because I had chosen a treat that made
me the same religion as them I was able
to get by without any issues
foreign
there's another great one that gives you
a damage Buff when your health is low
but mercenaries will randomly show up
and try to kill you
no matter what you choose there will be
plenty of ways for you to tell your
story and if you want to remove a trait
there are ways to do that too what a
view It's A Feast for the eyes off we go
[Music]
we'll let you discover that on your own
please
once you've built the perfect character
that's when your journey can really
begin
we took what we loved about skills and
perks from our previous games and put
them together to create an all-new skill
system
each time you level up you get a skill
point which can be used to unlock or
rank up skills
ranks are unlocked by completing
challenges associated with that skill
[Music]
become increasingly difficult as you
work your way to higher ranks
foreign
skill trees and four ranks per skill
there's a lot to choose from
[Music]
sociology skill because it lets you mind
control aliens
[Music]
boost pack out of the gate I'm boost
packing everywhere
maxing out my physical tree so I can get
neuro strikes and just punch my way
through combat
that one's a lot of fun
invest in the skills that suit your play
style
very much a stealth player so I'm out
there pickpocketing everyone
a favorite part about being stealthy
slowly creeping through vents like
you're in a movie
and then jumping out and springing on
people
whenever possible I like to talk my way
through situations these areas off
limits
fine I'll issue you an access card I'm
more of a run and Gun player
I like doing the death from above thing
where I'd boost pack over guys and I
throw land mines at them
you're gonna pay for that
I like blowing stuff up
[Music]
exploration is a key aspect of all our
gangs in Starfield there are four star
systems with new life resources and
Adventures
[Music]
our team worked hard to strike a balance
between fun and realism
we study data from NASA and a multitude
of other sources to help us make the
world feel believable
from the way we approached planetary
atmospheres to the way we place biomes
based on the planet's distance from the
Sun
once we had created a grounded world we
could start looking at all the things
that make that world fun
when you leave a planet and head into
space
you'll be navigating asteroid Fields
having chance meetings with interesting
strangers dog fighting in space and
exploring derelict ships
[Music]
it's all out there
ultimately it's about rewarding your
curiosity because whether it's on the
surface of a planet the alleys of a city
or the vastness of space you never know
what you'll find
[Music]
space exploration is possible thanks to
your ship your ship is almost like
having another character or home you can
make all your own I think you'll be
blown away by the amount of stuff you
can do
you can buy a ship I'm sure you can find
something you like customize and upgrade
that ship
and hire a crew to keep it up and
running
starts in spaceports
every Spaceport has a ship technician
where you can purchase sell and modify
ships anything I can help you with
maybe you start off with a speedy
fighter that's perfect for bounty
hunting
then you might round out your ship
roster with a hulking space braider to
run cargo missions or even do a little
smuggling
for now though we're going to take our
starting ship the frontier
and make some changes
you can customize and upgrade everything
you see here
and you have two ways to do that
you can quickly upgrade individual
systems like your weapons or Shields or
you can deep dive and enter the
shipbuilder mode here you can change
anything from the systems to the look
and layout
adding a new habitat module can give you
more room for crew
adding cowling can change your ship's
overall silhouette
an improved grab Drive allows for longer
distance space jobs
you can even fully customize your paint
job to get the exact look you want
the parts you choose to build with don't
just affect your ship's stats
they'll also affect what you can do
inside your ship
you can have modules for crafting
or for storing and displaying your
weapons
starfield's in-game ship manufacturers
bring their own look and feel to every
piece of your ship
from living quarters to cargo holds mess
halls and control rooms
thank you
our modified Frontier is a practical
ship but with a little creativity your
ship can look like almost anything you
want
different ways of customizing
platypus as I called it
where I had like a giant tail to it
[Music]
and we've done spiders we've done mix
so it's really whatever your imagination
is
and while you can build your home Among
the Stars the way you want to you're
probably not the only person who will
call your ship home
[Applause]
[Music]
ready to lift off when you are captain
engines ready
the frontier is fueled and ready captain
[Music]
some of the members of constellation can
join you on your journey these
companions can serve on your crew and
they'll always be there when you travel
we'll be traveling together until we
either find an artifact or this lead
Runs Dry
each companion comes with their own
valuable skills for your ships and
outposts
as well as unique quest lines eventually
some friendships might blossom into
romance I don't know that I've ever
really loved anyone
sub you and if you're looking for a
little extra help on your ship you can
always hire additional crew at
spaceports got any room on your ship for
someone like me
you'll also meet potential crew members
out in the world still think there might
be a spot for me on your ship I gotta
get off this rock
assigned crew to your ship or outposts
and their unique skills will affect how
they run
and just like companions most crew
members can lend a hand in the field
take Bosco for instance
these designed around the core basics of
a NASA machine please avoid getting shot
you might die I still want to give it
almost a humanoid personality so I
elongated the limbs this tends to make
him feel more human-like and give him a
little personality it is a shame
exploration requires so much bloodshed
using the ship building tools and crew
selection features in Starfield you'll
be able to build and Captain the ship of
your dreams
[Music]
let's take to the sky
we're putting you in the cockpit of your
very own spaceship and telling you that
you can do pretty much anything and that
is really cool for us as Developers
flight should be exciting and dangerous
and you should feel like you're in
complete control every step of the way
we've extended that sense of control to
ship combat it's not about just hitting
your triggers to fire your weapons
complex dance between your piloting
skills and our power allocation system
boosting power to your engines will make
your ship faster
powering up the ground dries will
shorten the amount of time it takes
before you can make a jump
and moving your power to your weapons
and shields means you're ready for a
fight
you should always be on your toes
because you're not alone out there
[Music]
unlocking the targeting control system
skill will allow you to zero in on
specific subsystems of the ship you
target
after destroying an enemy ship you can
loot The Remains from your cockpit
you can always turn any ship that
engages you into scrap
but you could also take a more personal
approach by docking with the Enemy
vessel and boarding their ship
once you've taken control of an enemy
ship it's yours
at your Fleet and retrieve it at any
Spaceport
but space is way more than fighting for
your life
just like when you're PlanetSide there
are plenty of sights to see and stops to
make on the way to your next adventure
like these massive star yards
[Music]
Walk The Halls talk to the crew maybe
get talked into buying a whole new ship
a civilian in moist let's see about
getting you a proper ship one worthy of
you maybe you'll dock with a gigantic
Battleship like the UC vigilance
[Music]
or rub elbows with the Galaxy's wealthy
Elite on a cruise ship fit for the Stars
there are plenty of personal encounters
to be had as well you can hail any ship
you come across to trade swap info or
maybe even commit an act of piracy let's
do this when I'm playing I generally go
crazy
um I definitely go like the more piracy
routes I want to take over ships I'm
going to afford ships I'm like this is
now mine I steal all these sandwiches
and put them you know in my cargo hold
that I have specifically for sandwiches
I don't want to play the hero but I want
to go out and just start taking things
from people as quickly as possible
some strangers might be looking for a
little human Connection in the darkness
of space
hello stranger I just finished cooking
up some food do you want to come on over
just pop on by
some of the best moments are the ones
you discover on your own
the thing I love most about Starfield is
that it is a Bethesda game through and
through it's typically about going to
strange new places meeting interesting
people and getting sidetracked on zany
Adventures then realizing two hours
later that you're involved in a
completely new story you'll
we thought we were the only ones to
leave Earth that DNA is so present here
it's in our Random Encounters it's in
our handcrafted quests
and it feels so cool to play it and just
make your own path in this universe
there are over a thousand planets out
there just waiting for you to visit
breaking ground on new planets exploring
every inch of a mostly untouched Galaxy
we want you to feel hope
sense of awe and wonder
times a little fear
we're giving you a massive playground
and a ton of toys and just setting you
free
[Music]
hey everybody we've shown you so much
stuff but we thought we'd just take a
little break and show you something a
little bit different you know we put so
much detail into our game worlds and we
love the opportunity to bring that into
the real world with our Collector's
Editions and for this game uh we've done
a watch it is the constellation
explorers watch this is the watch that
you actually get in the game that acts
as part of your HUD where it's the
compass and then environmental
information it connects to your phone to
give you notifications and other
information and we've also designed this
really cool case that it comes with
eastvont
yeah we really took as much care and
designed as cases we did the watch our
attention to detail in the game totally
translates to this inspired by the cases
that the astronauts used during the
Apollo era to bring back samples from
the moon it's got the intricate locking
mechanism authentic heavy comes with a
constellation patch native strap and the
overall functionality and believability
of this as something that would exist in
the world into Starfield Universe oh and
hey take this you'll find it very useful
out there and it even tells the time
we actually have something else now that
we're part of Xbox we get to work with
the amazing people on the Xbox Hardware
team and together we have created this
custom limited edition Starfield
controller it's awesome it is now you
know our favorite controller we love
this because it's inspired by the actual
controls of your spaceship
and not only that
we've created the first ever custom
headset with Xbox and this is a perfect
pairing with that controller
Frontier
on your signal
ready
[Music]
in every one of our games we always put
so much care into all those little
details that breathe life into our
worlds
but Starfield isn't just a Bethesda game
studios world it's a Bethesda game
studios Galaxy
so why go this big with Starfield
because we want to give you freedom on a
galactic level
the freedom to experience both the
exciting planets
and The Quiet Ones
scanning a planet before you land is a
great way to get a sneak peek at the
available resources you can use for
crafting building and customizing I
think what's cool about this whole
system that we we generate the planet
itself as a procedural content but the
handcrafted content itself comes as the
player Explorer
our system builds a planet as the player
approaches it and we stitch together the
luck of terrain after that we have the
system that adds interested locations
for the player to explore creatures to
encounter
or and plans to pick up
it allows us to add that touch of
environmental storytelling that Bethesda
is known for
teachers have been disrupting our
experiments their habitat isn't far from
here if you could take care of them for
us we would be in your debt so even if
your friends were to visit the same
planet that you had you would have a
different story to tell
[Music]
take this guy down
it's completely up to you how you want
to interact with each planet whether you
want to explore and see what you can
find
Harvest resources and be on your way
or simply take in the views
with the help of your scanner you'll
chart the Uncharted and discover exotic
wildlife
if you have the skills you can even
figure out that certain creatures and
plants you can build an outpost and
produce resources from those plants and
animals you can get experience and
rewards for fully surveying planets and
fully surveying a whole system
[Music]
we're concepting these creatures we
really wanted to think of them as
natural to the environment we didn't
want alien monsters we wanted native
wildlife
something you've never seen before
when it comes to our exteriors when the
sun moves all that light is calculated
in real time through the atmosphere our
biggest goal for lighting with Starfield
was to make the game feel more filmic to
use lighting and color to really make it
feel more cinematic
[Music]
foreign
exploring you can find a spot to set up
a base camp
outposts can be built almost anywhere on
any planet
and the habitat modules come in all
shapes and sizes filling all different
purposes you can even live in them
assign crew and companions to work at
your outposts for added bonuses and set
up extractors to harvest resources while
you're away
something cool we have this time is we
have a new fly cam where you can toggle
between on foot building or you can now
use a top-down isometric camera which
helps plan out larger parts of the
Outpost and placing those larger halves
so that way you can really plan your
structures and what the overall feel of
your Outpost is and then when you're on
your feet you can really decorate and
fine-tune things much easier
foreign
[Music]
and research stations in your outposts
to utilize any resources you find or
already have
mod your weapons to adapt them to your
playstyle different weapon sights and
Scopes larger magazines a selection of
grips and barrels different ammunition
like Explosive Rounds
all you stealth players out there will
surely need a suppressor
you can also choose to go Hands-On with
melee weapons
I think it's always a delicate balance
between like what's realistic what SIM
and what's Hollywood and I think we sort
of err on the side of like what's fun
for the player
with Starfield we've completely
overhauled our combat
it's more Dynamic the animations are
more fluid
it just feels great
we probably have more mods and more
weapons in this game than
I want to say any other game we've done
before
there's a lot of variety
upgraded gear is just one of the many
factors to pay attention to when
engaging in combat you may need to
switch things up based on your
environment
gravity is different for each planet and
boost packs are excellent for getting
around
and for giving you an edge in combat
[Music]
sometimes you'll even feel like you're
flying
[Music]
zero gravity environments pose a
different challenge firing a ballistic
weapon in zero g will actually push you
backwards
energy weapons on the other hand offer a
more stable shooting experience
we also have mag weapons
these are high-powered electromagnetic
induction ballistic arrays each Barrel
has its own targeting laser and can dish
out some serious damage
everything
whether you want to get up close and
personal with your own two Fists
or you like more compact weapons like
pistols and submachine guns
or maybe you prefer something bigger
starfield's got you covered
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thanks again for being with us today we
are just so grateful that you've taken
the time and spent it here I know there
was probably a lot to take in there's a
lot to the game even more than we could
show here you know as we play it we're
always sharing these unique and special
moments that only a game like this can
bring when I think about what makes it
special it really is the people here
this game is a reflection of the
incredible and passionate team that made
it all of them putting something special
of themselves into it so let's hear some
of their favorite moments
I love the way that our final
combination of all the new tech has come
together to create some of the most
beautiful sunsets and sunrises we've
ever had in any of our games
word that comes to mind is vast
I like to use our photo mode to take
Rockstar photos
I just love that constant feel of
Discovery and wow I can't believe that
there's more here I'm most excited about
our Outpost Building Systems
my favorite part is every time you step
out on a planet it's a unique experience
I spent all this time building your ship
and you see it on the landing pad these
things are gigantic it's the kind of
thing that you just can't get anywhere
else
there's something about seeing a tower
over in the distance and going I know
the gravity is low here I think I can
make that jump
my favorite part is biomes spaceships
audio design planets the day night cycle
those details matter to me diplomacy
exploration Freedom the ending basket
obviously I love the robot so much the
incredible amount of Worlds we created
sniper rifles come on lever action
rocket launcher brain sprout
I love but some people might find creepy
I don't know and that's where I've been
the thing that I enjoy most about the
game is the freedom to be who you want
to be do what you want to do
it's what you've come to expect from a
Bethesda title but on a much bigger
scale
[Music]
on behalf of all of us we can't wait for
you to play Starfield and make your own
special moments
three minutes ago
[Music]
constellation
you are
[Music]
alive
thank you
[Music]
what are you doing don't you think
until
what my metal on
tell Basim the story of the feather
our tradition of the feather comes from
Egypt
the feathers of the Heron were dipped in
the blood of the targets
the feathers Forge our paths remind us
of who we are
who we can be
order has held dominion over men and
their Empires for centuries strike
quickly and end this
swallow your questions serve without
complaint who is she to tell you when to
strike
everything you do serves the hidden ones
that is a strange kind of freedom
you are not the first to walk the
Shadows broken pour your pain into the
Brotherhood
foreign
we are messengers of Justice
and not the final judges
he knows not what he needs
have you not wondered that's your nature
[Music]
Humanity has always hunted for knowledge
in the unknown
the Wonder is
not that the field of stars is so vast
that we have measured it
[Music]
foreign
we're all here because we're committed
to the biggest question of all
what's
[Applause]
[Music]
you're part of constellation now
part of our family
[Music]
we do not fully understand all that is
at work here no final group in the stars
to be unraveling this mystery
follow you from here on out to Captain
grab jump is ready I love this park
these artifacts could be everything
we've been looking for another great
secret to the universe is asking us to
unravel
human settlements throughout the Galaxy
could be at risk
we are not stopping whatever lies at the
end of this road
will change Humanity
forever
This Is Where We Belong
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
oh we're finally doing this are we
because I was going to make a sandwich
[Music]
okay
let's do it
[Music]
what do I think about heroes
well
we've all seen them haven't we swatting
about the place
with their disproportionately high
cheekbones and comically massive weapons
roughing up Bandits because they like to
rough up Bandits don't they living it up
with the common folk every single night
on a day-to-day basis I'll say the two
Heroes me someone who's breaking you
ground with fruit with veg on the
agricultural side of things just look at
them not wafting around mythical
creatures
that's what they are
wafters yeah well done you see I'm not
here to slay legendary beasts
I'm here to conquer the vegetable not a
euphemism let's face it the age of
Heroes is over this is the age of
innovation this if you will is the age
of death
one moment
this is awkward
yeah
[Music]
ah
she can feel them
slipping through her soul
following the threads of her mind
she's here to find them
I want to hide
she needs her help with a promise
a question
huh
but it's never so simple is it
stem has a prize
there's always a part of you that
changes
a part of you that darkens
and a part of you that dies over there
at the pool
I can feel them feel them everywhere The
Lost Ones they are watching us
thank you
can see us
[Music]
what happened it's time to find out how
can we make it happen it's time to find
out
it's time to find out are they waiting
what are you waiting for I'm here
[Music]
watching
all right
where are they where are you what do
they want
I'm scared
their eyes everywhere can feel them
boring into her which is she supposed to
do do something else what do you want me
to do
[Music]
lost
not anymore
are you ready for what you will find
here
what we will find
nothing
[Music]
they are waiting
to us
and
feel
your mind your
your whole hearts of here that are
broken you can be whole
the grief of the rage
[Music]
has led me to this place we've come so
far not far enough
say it you already tell them
I'm here
what if we get lost forever
what will happen to them what will
happen to you
I will not let them down she is ready
[Music]
go
who are these around you Sarah
those you have saved
or those you bled to death
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
they're everywhere
but the world here
belongs to syndicates
[Music]
I want to survive
I have to play their game
looks like I'm all in
I'm out
thank you
[Music]
there she is
held back my whole life
and now
I just need a chance to finally be free
wherever that takes me
I'm here to offer you a way out okay
get off my ship Jalen give me a chance
you're gonna have to trust me it'll be
dangerous risky but if you pull this off
you'll never look over your shoulder
again
[Music]
foreign
the underworld shows no mercy
but it's a big Galaxy out there and I'm
gonna risk it off
[Music]
Star Wars Outlaws coming 2024
thank you
I'm about free but I kept trying not
strong enough
[Music]
foreign
forever
[Music]
welcome to the scum bar the most
notorious Tavern on melee Island
wall-to-wall Rogues and Scoundrels
so tell me which ship is right for you A
big ship a luxury ship a ship with just
a splash of je ne sais quoi the legend
of Monkey Island you mean Governor guy
brush but freeport's not set foot out of
that Mansion for almost a year
hey what do you think you're doing I
told you no autographs
though I see you have a meet and greet
ticket and I guess it's not every day
that you get to meet the mighty pirate
guy Rush Street wood the legend of
Monkey Island
the Chuck has turned the memories of
this island into a prison for guybrush
well well what
what
damn
you need this
beans may be very different from the sea
of Thieves you know
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
all right guys it's a simple job
standing out now nothing to it
[Music]
everybody hit the floor
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Appalachia what a sight a verdant
Wonderland of Promise plucked from
post-atomic flight the fruit of years of
prudent progress and determined
Reclamation and 15 million dwellers
worth of keen imagination from the heart
of West Virginia to the depths of the
pits
[Music]
no matter if you roam alone or spend
your time with friends you'll find a
home in Appalachia where the good times
never end there are relics to uncover
from a time before the war along with
loads of friendly folks to meet and
enemies Galore our world is all changing
greater bubbles are over
we embark on Expeditions into thrilling
new unknowns yes from Appalachian
settlements to Nuka World on tour you're
never short on things to do or places to
explore think you've seen it all hey
well how about this pack your bags for
an escape of Epicurean Bliss put your
rad shield on and fix your hair up
pretty because we're headed for the
boardwalk of Atlantic City
so there you have it now you know
there's a million ways to make the
Wasteland your waste home and when you
hear Adventure calling when you're
looking for some kicks answer the call
answer
the call of all 76
play it now with Xbox game pass
I know you're ready you've got this
oh
my let's tweak the car's performance for
the next one
amazed
[Music]
foreign
play it day one with Game Pass
and all that ever will be
I have seen betrayal
endurance
ambition
courage
I am the one who knows
thank you
for perhaps
of revealed disconnected from Fate's
flow
unseen forces move against me hungry
knowledge of mystery long cat hidden
that threatens to unravel reality
itself
[Music]
say Tamriel
foreign
[Music]
Toronto is under attack
no sector there's something different
about no sector this time
they've taken over most of the city and
the rounding up omnics they need our
help
people are answering the instance recall
New Blood on the key and we have so much
to teach them
we can stop no sector maybe we can save
the city coming through
been a while Vivian as if I didn't have
enough problems already
smash through anything that gets in our
way
and what's another business I hate to
interrupt the moment but I'm picking up
reports of more attacks in other cities
it's a fight day one I say let's give it
to him
[Music]
engaged
Target mark
time to create peace with bullets
[Music]
the world is coating on us
thank you
[Music]
what is this place it looks like we're
in a palace what the hell is going on
who are these people no idea but if
they're attacking us our only choice is
fighting back hey look over there
can you get us out of here so you're
telling me your thieves who steal hearts
and you just happen to stumble into this
world
the rebel core will always help the
fantasy just as the Phantom thieves have
helped
never forget that we're United Force who
can rely on each other
used to be grateful to have been made my
subjects but your test matterless Little
Friends
unfortunately returning will be no easy
feat
somewhere deep inside I know you realize
things can't go on like this
so will you take a stand beside us yeah
let's show them what we got
[Applause]
[Music]
play it day one with Game Pass
good
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
together
oh my God
oh turns up dude yeah dude
[Music]
huh
there's got to be a way out of this
Johnny
I'm dying
there's nothing can stop that
[Music]
V
my name is Songbird
I'm an nus intelligence analyst I know
about the bomb ticket in your head
and I can save your life
what's the catch
I need you to get to Dogtown
residents president managed to crash her
space force one and throughout humble
District man's got a thousand and one
reasons to want Myers as a hostage
sleeper agents
time to wake them up so nusa is tossing
us back into The Fray huh stay sharp
we're in the Wolf's Den now
get Myers out of there time to Evac
her safety is the top priority
they catch us out here we're dead
wait hear that
God almighty
this way
and ratted us up you know the treason
ain't never black and white it's a
charade V wherever she goes people get
hurt bodies drop just one what Songbird
promised me
secure
the situation has changed you need to
know if you're with me illusion of
Freedom draws in the desperate take your
truth be come on got iron in your head
you've got to put it to someone's head
pull the trigger
do anything and do it soon I'll die
[Music]
thank you
people don't like you very much do they
sent here to the living lands
by an emperor who couldn't bother to
come himself
to investigate some plague
that seems to be corrupting of their
souls
you want us to trust you
but the truth is
you scare us
the way you fight
power you will see
you're either here to save us
or destroy us
[Music]
so now that you have all this power
You're Gonna Do With It
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go get paid
that worked
who's the boss because he knows how to
handle the Empire we cannot trust those
officers they take our credits now but
what stops them from stabbing Us in the
back
thanks
hit that button
nice one
hang on tight little buddy
foreign
okay we'll figure this out
Shield
[Music]
hey Nick
this is getting bad
let's try this out
[Music]
I think that went pretty well right
thank you
[Music]
that was close
I got the package where are you waiting
for you and jaunt us hope
I said I got it what else matters
anytime soon
um well they'll probably forgive me
country
there's Johnson's hope we made it next
[Music]
time
thank you
hey Andy
your late cake Doc is waiting what are
you worried no
okay
no picture Troy what
be careful
tonka's a broker not a friend
you can't be trusted
who can out here
see you back at the ship
round two and I still like my odds
okay this
back already
I told you she's fresh but she's good
who's this
who's a friend
join
job was more complicated than you said
Danka
lift
hey these are toys
they're Investments
wait
we haven't met
I don't really know many of you
stealing illegal Contraband running with
syndicates I could say you're a threat
to the Empire
but I won't have to if you're smart
[Music]
thanks but I'm smart enough to get
myself out of trouble you pay the tax
just like everyone else whoa kid let's
just relax
[Music]
you won't make a doctor shower alive
Maybe
old Troopers we have reports of The
Fugitive in Georgia's hope move to
apprehend
Italian
uh could be I told you not to trust her
it's not the first time we've around the
empire
we need to leave yeah no kidding
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
let's jump
all right
we made it
foreign
[Music]
so where do we go next
anywhere we want
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Star Wars Outlaws come in 2024.
hey folks I'm current Divina and I just
got the chance to see 30 minutes of
Allen week to gameplay it was hands off
but there's a lot to talk about and I
have a lot of Impressions to share with
you
before we jump right into this there's a
few things I need to clear up and that
is some stuff I love one I love Alan
awake two I love survival horror and
three I'm a big old fan of detective
mystery games and not only when they
first announce Alan Wake 2 as a survival
horror did my mind explode but what I
saw was a trifecta of all those things
because Alan Wake 2 is just as much a
survival horror as it is a detective
investigation game and that's got this
guy very excited so what I got to see
was basically an extended look at what
was revealed at summer game Fest the
gameplay I saw surrounded around Saga
Anderson and her investigating cauldron
lake with her partner Alex Casey with a
single button press Saga teleports to
the Mind place was an actual physical
room that you can move around in that
shows your evidence board as well as a
map a place to upgrade your weapons and
also do profiling which we'll get more
into in a moment as you collect evidence
you are able to actually physically
place the evidence on the wall on your
own to be able to connect your own dots
which is something I'm extremely excited
for because it feeds into my detective
loving heart so if you're not familiar
the Crux of the scheme is that Saga is
trying to find Alan Wake or at least
investigate what happened uh in bright
Falls 13 years ago and what unravels is
this big old horrific
cultist focused thing where there's
ritualistic killings and that bleeds out
into many many more Mysteries and things
that are Supernatural uh that of course
in one way or another align with what
has happened to Alan awake in order to
progress in the world and get more of a
connection to the dark place which is
where Alan Wake is trapped from the
first game actually connecting evidently
fine helps Saga make connections that
actually manifest things from the dark
place into reality which is what allows
the player to progress kind of allowing
this puzzle like element but of course
it's not just about the investigation
because it is also yes indeed a
full-blown survival horror I'm talking a
limited inventory inventory management
scarce resources and Incredibly Close
Quarter combat uh that was extremely
intense to watch so in the demo we saw
Saga face up against who what I assume
is one of these ritualistic killing
dudes uh wearing a face mask and even
that fight was just extremely grueling
they're intense they murmur to
themselves you also have many things in
Your Arsenal like uh one of the things
that's coming back from the first game
is flashing your light on these things
to get rid of this Darkness this this
sort of like Supernatural thing that is
shielding them which gives you an
opportunity to then shoot them open up a
spot sometimes use a flare which will
then show other weak spots for you able
to hit now for those of you who are
familiar with the first one you may know
that that's really more of an action
adventure and the combat has been
criticized for being a little repetitive
over time of just like flashing her
flashlight and a dude and then shooting
them repeat and while remedy has
vocalized that they aware of that
concern that is something that kind of
held the first one back uh they're going
into this one without awareness but
without being able to play it
for the most part it did seem like that
similar routine of flashing your light
on this dude getting rid of this
darkness and then you shoot now of
course it did seem much more in close
quarters uh the flashlight like using
the flashlight seems to work even
quicker but that's kind of a good
balance considering that the enemies are
now more up close and personal also one
thing I saw there was less enemies but
they were more aggressive than they were
in the first one the first one
definitely like threw horrors of these
dudes at you while you were just like
shooting light at them shooting them
light shoot light shoot the closest
thing I can compare it to in a way is
sort of Resident Evil 2 combat
specifically because the Resident Evil 2
combat is always really up close it's in
close quarters and you're usually only
facing off a few zombies at a time but
it can still feel really dire and while
that had a similar feeling and weight in
just from what I saw I still have a
concern whether or not you know this
routine of flashlight shooting
flashlight shooting uh will actually
like stick through for an entire camp
but of course course in traditional
survival horror that also means that
there's a great deal of exploration
there's a great deal of slower pacing
especially time to build a brooding
atmosphere and also of course resource
management and some minor puzzle solving
during my time Saga saw you there was a
shotgun behind a glass case and in order
to get the shotgun you'd have to find a
Post-It note that then would give you a
clue to the combination for the lock
that would then give you the shotgun and
that's like sort of like that is the
Symmetry that I am looking for when I'm
when I'm playing the survival horror
because it kind of gives me the agency
in that I don't need to get that gun if
I don't need to but then there's that
sense of like you know puzzle solving
involved that just that feeds into the
things I love most but of course this
wouldn't be a remedy or even an Alan
Wake game without its atmosphere so
again this is in the Pacific Northwest
or at least the section I saw with Saga
and it is
rooting and that's where some of the
elements from control I started to see
really bleed through aesthetically there
was this fantastic part where you go
into what is called the overlap that is
where the dark place starts to feed into
reality and it's this incredible moment
of saga just like walking through a
forest with these flashing ominous red
lights that have no Source whatsoever
this tense White Noise just building uh
and it was like it's this sort of flow
of like investigating a pudding of of
putting evidence together action tense
combat but also the opportunity to
explore and let something sink in that
really really made what I saw feel
effective and kind of like the last bit
of like the whole investigative part is
of course profiling not don't only do
just peace evidence together but you
actually have the opportunity to sit at
a table with pictures of characters
you've met and you actually have to ask
yourself questions and ask them the
right questions will event unlocks
things within saga's mind and putting
herself in like the shoes of the people
she's trying to profile profiling people
is necessary to not only gather evidence
but also piece things together so you
can manifest it from the dark place into
reality and it's just this is the
trifecta I'm talking about like The
Surreal spooky dark uh nature of the
game with investigative stuff I love it
I'm a big fan I'm excited uh but that
isn't to say it was very specific to the
developers also told me it's Corky it's
a quirky game it's retaining it's kind
of Twin Peaks isms that we saw in the
first one and that remedy just seems to
have to a T through all their games now
if you're new to Alan Wake don't worry
it is not necessary for you to play the
first one also with that said it's this
is a game that's connected to remedy's
other titles like control and even
Quantum break in some small little ways
but that is not necessary like to be
able to be invested in the lore to
understand Alan Wake 2 they're being
very trans parent that this should be an
entry point for anyone despite how
involved you are in remedy's other games
so with that being said I only got to
see a sliver a bit there's still a lot
that I have to see and thankfully uh you
can actually go to gamespot.com we'll
have a link in the description below for
my actual written editorial piece uh
which will give some insight to some of
the developers I got to talk to and give
a little bit more insight but that being
said this is a game that I've been
wanting to see for 13 years and it's
kind of remarkable not only see it
finally happen but see it connecting the
dots in ways that just feeds into things
I really really like but we will have to
find out more when the game releases
this year on October 17th
[Music]
thank you
there you are
time to vanish
Ed
getting away
[Music]
alhamdulillah
I am glad you are safe
[Music]
alhamdulillah a first of many
achievements to combust him we should
only hope there's still much work to do
[Music]
while our Focus was on our rule
full of quietly scouted the city for
where we could direct more bureaus I
have found dwellings in three districts
that are most unassuming
the bid and Rebecca have arrived from
alamut and set off to al-abasiya and
karch
I will make my way to sharkia shortly
and I will join Rebecca in car
where corruption is as common as the
Arid air
see Abu Jafar about some things he's
been working on then come find us
have a look awesome I may have something
that is of interest to you
[Music]
resourceful as always
my thanks abujafar
[Music]
you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
let us reconsider the approach
[Music]
thank you
act as usual a girl who likes me said
she and Ali's followers are trying to
overthrow the prince what Madness they
will surely fail
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hey
the sky is safe my friend
survey the area in kidu
foreign
[Music]
what I wish to know and no more need I
this day
[Music]
thank you
one one
me
[Music]
thank you
whatever
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Music]
welcome to Avatar frontiers of Pandora
the first person action adventure game
that invites you to explore the engaging
world of Avatar in an immersive open
World Experience I'm Dede deanfeldt game
director and I'm excited to reveal
what's waiting for you on Pandora
story of our game begins when the RDA
expands their operations to the Western
frontier
John Mercer one of the leaders of the
RDA abducts you and other Navi children
from your home to teach you the ways of
humans hoping to mold you and Turn you
against your own people
but his plan is interrupted by the
battle of the Hallelujah mountains and
you are put into emergency cryosleep
when you awaken 15 years later you are a
stranger in your birthplace knowing the
dangers posed by the RDA you set out to
take them down and look to secure the
health of other Navi Clans
initially you're perceived as an
outsider so you have to reconnect with
your lost Navi Heritage to gain their
trust
on your adventure you'll find your own
path as you discover what it means to be
Navi you'll explore new regions of
Pandora each with their own unique
biomes
the king Law Forest is a lush rainforest
brimming with life and dense vegetation
in the shade of awe-inspiring floating
mountains
this is the home of the Arana hay a clan
of peaceful Weavers who will guide you
on your first hunt and on your first
flight
will show you the way to The Rookery
where you can bond for life with your
very own ecrom
the ikran is a devoted companion that
you can name feed and customize
experiment with acrobatics and feel a
rush of adrenaline as you dive from the
sky and explore the open world of
Pandora from the air if you travel North
you'll get to the upper Plains
an expansive grassland filled with
contrasts and open views as far as the
eye can see
the nomadic seswa Clan live here in
symbiosis with gigantic beasts called
sakuru
earn the Clan's trust and they will
teach you the art of writing dire horses
and further west the mysterious clouded
Forest
were hidden in the Mist nothing is as it
seems
here lives the cafeteri a clan of
healers with their own dark reasons to
stay hidden
operations are threatening the balance
of Pandora
they build facilities of all Sciences to
exploit resources at any cost spreading
devastating pollution
in the process animals are hurt and
poached
you'll need to stop the RDA from
ravaging your home and when you are
ready you will take the fight to them
as a child of Two Worlds you can learn
to master multiple combat Styles your
powerful instincts allow you to get an
overview of the battlefield Mark your
enemies and identify weak points
traditional Navi weapons are versatile
and precise you can use the Longbow to
hit long-range targets or the staff's
link to set up traps
for a more explosive approach you can
leverage your human training and go for
the blast of an assault rifle a shotgun
or go bigger with the occasional rocket
launcher
foot you can also rely on your
Incredible strength to take down amp
units above the clouds your ikron will
help you in aerial combat against the
RDA
destroying RDA facilities will have a
tangible impact on your world
with the pollution removed Pandora heals
you'll be able to harvest the best
quality material again and craft better
gear and weapons
you will also find ingredients to cook
and make meals to get stronger
as you keep discovering what it truly
means to become Navi you'll improve your
skills by connecting to Ay through the
Taurus shoe plant and learn from the
memories of your ancestors skill
upgrades can improve many aspects of
your character such as your natural
agility to move through the world your
stealth approach when hunting or
fighting or the handling of your weapons
and mounts
Avatar frontiers of Pandora is a
captivating action-adventure game
designed to maximize the power of new
gen consoles and PC you will be able to
play the full story campaign in single
player or with a friend online in
two-player Co-op
we invite you to explore this world of
wonder
Navi
take down the RDA to protect Dora
[Music]
foreign
as a river and that River has been
flowing Swift and Shore for 13 long
years since the last entry in the Prince
of Persia franchise the somewhere aptly
titled Forgotten Sands with Prince of
Persia the Lost Crown Ubisoft appears to
be looking to the past and present in
the hopes of creating a future for the
franchise a return to Prince of Persia's
roots in 2D platforming on the
foundations built by modern metroidvania
titles however the question of whether
the game has anything Innovative of its
own to offer remains to be seen
foreign
[Music]
game Fest Prince of Persia the Lost
Crown is a 2d action adventure
platformer developed by Ubisoft
Montpellier the studio behind the
Beloved Rayman Legends at a recent
preview event at Ubisoft Montpellier
studio in France we had a chance to go
Hands-On with an early build of the game
playing on both PC and Nintendo switch
for around two hours in a presentation
director munia Rady spoke of a desire to
bring back the core ingredients of
Prince of Persia platforming puzzle
solving time-based powers and a sense of
adventure this new outing is set in a
legendary Persia that is described as an
age of Heroes and gods players take on
the role of Sargon a young and impetuous
hero who is part of a superhero-esque
gang of seven Warriors known as The
Immortals Sargon and the Immortals
journey to mount CAF a land cursed with
time anomalies to rescue the kidnapped
son of the queen of Persia presumably
the titular prince in immediately
apparent is The Game's striking visual
style combining 3D foreground
environments with painterly backgrounds
its vast world is made up of several
visually distinct biomes beams of light
beat down over the deserted streets of
the lower City leaves drift serenely
through an autumnal Forest sand dunes
swallow crumbled ruins in the depths
beneath the city the backgrounds are
richly detailed and are clearly intended
to demonstrate Persia's Rich
environmental diversity beyond the
stereotypical deserts and temples seen
in Western pop culture but always with a
high fantasy flavor Sargon could
encounter behemothic beings working a
lava fueled Forge bands of floating
scripture weaving through sand filled
caves and broken statues Frozen in
mid-air Bound by Mount calf's temporal
curse
Sargon explores Mount calf in the way of
every modern metroidvania moving through
environments that make up larger areas
of an interconnected World offering
plenty of scope for exploration
shortcuts and secrets
traversing around the world feels fun
and effortless an obvious result of
Ubisoft montpellier's 2D platforming
Heritage and each area feels like the
product of a team with expertise in
crafting instantly legible flow-inducing
platforming playgrounds subtle
navigational AIDS occasionally nudge you
in the right direction but many rooms
have multiple exits teasing undiscovered
challenges and rewards our demo did not
include the game's tutorial but that was
hardly an issue as every move you expect
from a modern platformer is present and
correct from an air Dash to a wall jump
and it all feels natural the process of
getting from A to B is a constant
delight and the series Infamous traps
make a welcome return in a form of
platforming puzzles an isolated section
from later in the game showcased a
challenging run which hinted at the kind
of Twitchy Pixel Perfect platforming
Pleasures found in Hollow Knight for
combat encounters Sargon has a pair of
swords at his disposal as well as a
quick-fire bow that can transform into a
chakram-esque boomerang dodging and
parrying is fundamental to success there
is no blocking creating a high risk High
reward combat system with enemies
dishing out significant punishment for
poorly timed moves
Sargon also has a variety of combat
powers that seem drawn from the catalog
of generic 2D video game special moves
in our demo these included a powerful
wave attack a lunging thrust and an area
of effect healing spell
certain enemy attacks indicated by
flashing eyes trigger special counter
moves if successfully parried and
function as an instant kill against
grunts or an opportunity to take a
sizable Chunk from a boss's health bar
thankfully for a game that rewards
parrying the Lost Crown appears to run
at a locked 60 FPS even on Nintendo
switch and its slick presentation makes
combat feel fluid and responsive and
looks spectacular too sargon's
animations and movements throughout the
world are underpinned by prominent anime
inspired visual flourishes Dash moves
trigger a flash of abstract color and
instant kill parries include Dynamic 3D
camera moves dramatic color shifts and
super satisfying animations it looks
impressive and it's much more than mere
window dressing rather everything is
designed to be in service of how the
game feels much like special moves and
counters in 2D fighting games a
successful Parry is as much an aesthetic
reward as a mechanical weapon
Sargon has time Powers at his disposal
thanks to simmer a mythical bird and god
of time and knowledge drawn from real
Persian Legend in our preview these
abilities were limited to an air Dash
and a kind of teleporting power known as
the shadow of simmer players can
crystallize their shadow of Sargon in a
particular place and then teleport back
into it at the Press of a button warping
through hazards and enemies as they do
so though the move is accompanied by a
satisfying rewind sound unlike the sands
of time the power only affects Sargon
and not the world around him meaning
that with some creative thinking on the
part of the player Sargon can navigate
past mobile hazards or pop-up behind
enemies as the shadow can be
crystallized at any point including in
mid-air or during a combo it opens up
many tantalizing opportunities for
combat and exploration simmer is one of
a number of creatures friends and foes
drawn directly from Persian folklore and
for the development team ensuring
accurate sensitive representation of
Persian mythology was key it's clear
that Ubisoft Montpellier sees the game
as an opportunity to show the influence
Persian culture has had on wider
mythology from around the world one boss
battle sees players fight a fierce
semanticore a creature widely seen
across Greek Egyptian and medieval Arts
but the team were Keen to highlight its
roots in Persian mythology there is a
sense that the team is Keen to
acknowledge the franchise's own
mythology too animations frequently
reference past entries such as a
finisher that directly quotes the iconic
acrobatic Vault from the sands of time
trilogy
and a mini boss lifted directly from the
1989 original albeit reworked into a
much more traditional combat encounter
their hope is that the Lost Crown is not
a reboot of the franchise but a love
letter to it with all that said there is
a caveat if this short previews anything
to go by the Lost Crown feels an awful
lot like a case of familiar notes being
played well Sargon can equip power
bestowing amulets just like Hollow
Knight's charms in an area called The
Sacred archives blind Invincible jailers
hunt Sargon inserted rooms and are
functionally identical to Metroid dreads
Emmys even the in-game conversations
with NPCs strongly evoke the anime style
portraits of Hades much like how
Immortals Phoenix Rising appear to be a
distinctly post breath of the wild
creation it's hard to play The Lost
Crown without constantly being reminded
of the modern greats of the metroidvania
genre and Beyond this isn't necessarily
a bad thing I like Immortals I love
Hollow Knight and I enjoyed why I played
of the Lost round two but it remains to
be seen whether it offers anything truly
Innovative or simply stands on the
shoulders of greatness we'll find out
when Prince of Persia the Lost Crown is
released in January 2024. for all the
latest Prince of Persia news and for
everything else from summer game Fest
make sure you're subscribed to GameSpot
we got to play an hour and a half of
cyberpunk 2077 Phantom Liberty and there
is a lot more to it than we initially
thought so let's talk about it
we got to play an hour and a half of the
game we're playing it on PC we had the
devs with us so they were able to answer
all of our questions the demo was the
first couple of missions of phantom
Liberty we got to uh save the president
whose plane crashed in Dogtown which is
the new area in the game which is
nestled in Pacifica yes uh so it is part
of the map however it is tough to get in
and out and sort of what we saw is it
was right after V had been smuggled into
Dogtown yes exactly and then we did like
whole mission where we found like an
apartment like a safe house to like hide
her away had like her confrontation and
then she asked us to go find Solomon
Reed which is Idris elba's character the
king when you first meet Idris Elba or
Solomon Reed he is a Sleeper Cell in
Dogtown he's basically been in cover for
what 11 years I think they said
something like that and you basically
need to get him out of it and he has a
very Gruff foreboding presence as you
expect Idris Elba to have there's a good
quest line where he asks if you've been
followed and you're like no no I haven't
been followed and uh turns out you
totally were followed yeah but the
reason so we didn't get to play this
Mission but the reason we were followed
is because we didn't do enough prep work
before meeting Solomon Reed they were
saying exactly had we done that mission
before and like kind of found the clues
that we'd be followed we could have
changed the outcome there was so much
potential for variation based on what
they were described obviously like we
didn't get a chance to see how those
changes played out but they said like
depending on what you say when you first
get confronted by Solomon he might end
up actually really pissed and like leave
and not want to help you and I was like
well what happens if yeah what happened
what happened without him good example
of that too I would say is uh so you
saved the president in the first mission
you take her to a safe house we kind of
they had to skip around a little bit so
we were missing some of the context but
when the president asked you to find
Solomon read The Sleeper Cell she asked
you to take an oath because you're a
unofficial official secret agent for the
new United States yes and you can take
the oath or you don't have to and if we
decided not to take the oath and Johnny
who returns obviously Johnny silverhand
Keanu Reeves yeah was like yeah V like
like Stick it to the Man like don't help
like like stay away uh from all that but
apparently you can also take the oath
and Johnny's pissed at you for taking
the oak but but I think Johnny to be
honest was one of my favorite parts of
what we saw of the story because it's
kind of it seems like it's diving into
another side of his character that we
didn't see which is the part of him that
served in the military and was a
deserter I really like Johnny in the
base game I thought he brought a lot of
Gravitas and energy to the story but I
feel like there were aspects of him that
weren't super well explored and almost
kind of uh like different sides of his
personality that kind of butted heads
and I'm curious to see what they explore
especially if they're heading down this
uh sort of like ex-military dessert
Direction and it really makes it feel
like integrated into the main game
because he is so involved it doesn't
feel like it's a side tangent I mean the
whole motivation for saving the
president is Songbird the person who
like contacts you on the radio puts out
the SOS
she promises like I can get rid of the
chip in your head so it like almost
reads as like an alternate path to like
progress the main story potentially
we're not really sure how it'll play out
they didn't really answer our question
about that we were like so does this tie
into the main story and they said well
it's there are things like The Witcher
um it's similar to how uh hearts of
stone in The Witcher 3 how you'd get the
the mark on geralt's face and people in
the story would comment on it yeah but
it didn't necessarily tie directly into
it but the way they're setting this up
it seems like it might tie more into the
main story and it got us thinking like
could this potentially lead to a
different ending something like that
which again they were kg about mostly
because they just don't want to spoil it
which I think is totally fair but I I
get the feeling that it will affect the
ending to some degree which I think is
really cool one thing that I was really
impressed by with Johnny and this kind
of leans into a whole other thing was I
immediately noticed that his character
model looked way better than this game
they like redid it and then that gets
into a whole thing that they were
talking to us about which is they have
actually touched like the whole game and
have made a ton of changes which I was
not expecting Pavel sasco who is with us
uh Quest director at CD Proctor added
for cyberpunk was saying that there's
not a system that they didn't either
tweak update or just redo entirely and
it's it's impressive and I think it's
going to breathe life into the entire
experience totally yeah I mean just like
a small example they gave was how they
wanted to reimagine the way um like
Health Works in combat I mean if you
remember cyberpunk space combat it gets
pretty hard at the point and that where
I remember just like every five seconds
I just feel like shooting up just
because like you're just constantly
getting hit and so they they wanted to
change like the way damage works so that
you're not needing to do that as much
and they said so because of that they
make
um actual like Health rare to find yeah
it's actually a cool down and it's a lot
more effective it's a lot more effective
and that also then uh leans into like
other stuff like they've completely
changed the weight armor works now it's
no longer tied to clothing clothing it's
now like tied to your cybernetics and
they've completely reworked the way
cybernetics work as well yeah which
really excited it's probably one of the
most interesting things that they've
changed because this time I mean it was
hard to get a full understanding of how
it worked because we were only just kind
of like guided through the menus got to
Peak it but uh it's similar and that you
can install a bunch of cybernetics but
you can't just go crazy right from the
start install a bunch of cybernetics all
over your body you have actually limit
you you have a limit that you can
increase as you I think level up and get
more cyber genetics and as you progress
you'll be able to get uh get more and
eventually uh once you hit the threshold
you will start to get debuffs for having
all of these which is sort of supposed
to simulate cyberpsychosis um which is
cool because that is a big part of the
cyberpunk universe and that was
kind of absent in terms of your
character yeah in the vanilla game I
don't think it's going to get as crazy
as like no but we saw in Edge Runners
for example sure but it's neat that like
there will be actual drawbacks to just
yes cyber cybering yourself up they want
to give a weight to the cybernetics in a
way they kind of lacked in the base game
and then there's like so much more that
they talked about uh there's the skill
tree completely reworked the way skills
work yeah they said they wanted to get
away from skills being like percentage
based where it just like you know you
are getting stronger but it doesn't it's
like stat Buffs it doesn't feel like
you're getting stronger so now they said
they wanted to go more in like a perk
based Direction where it actually feels
like you add a thing and you can feel
the substantial like there's I have a
new ability now so curious to see how
they'll actually feel but I mean based
on both that and the cybernetics like I
feel like that's gonna completely change
the way that game flows I was excited to
play Phantom Liberty story wise I I had
my issues with cyberpunk 2077 story but
overall I enjoyed those characters I
enjoyed that world and I and I liked a
lot of the narrative threads in that
game
um so I was excited to see what they do
with Phantom Liberty totally
um but I think honestly what I am most
excited about is revisiting the original
game with all of these changes and
updates and just seeing how that changes
not the story story is the same but just
how it changes like how I interact with
that world how I uh get stronger how I
level up my cybernetics How I build my
character and I I think that's going to
draw a lot of people totally to it I
mean there's like I feel like there's
just more stuff I keep remembering that
they added like they've completely
reworked the whole police system now
that was a big that is an important one
to talk about I feel like we should talk
about that yeah because people like
complained about it because it was it's
not great it wasn't very good so they've
reworked the way it works now so I think
they said like level one they'll
basically just like check the area
around yeah so wherever like if you ran
someone over and they get alerted
they'll come to that area check it out
if you're gone probably won't find you
but if you're still there and you keep
causing trouble two stars three stars
and then it builds up to yeah so at
level five they straight up call Max
tack on you yeah um and they said we
unfortunately we didn't get there
because we we did we're mainlining the
story and we died and I was like but
they say that you actually have a boss
fight yeah you have to do against them
which I think is really cool yeah like
that seems like a fun challenge that
like I want to pop in with my like
endgame character and just like see if I
can like survive and take out next yeah
like that would be cool it was kind of
nuts how much they've added to this game
like I think we knew going in you know
they're gonna have a good story they're
gonna have future Zelda in it and and I
was feeling confident that that stuff
would probably be pretty good what
really impressed me was their
willingness to take this as an
opportunity to also just like go back in
and almost rewrite the DNA yes rewriting
the DNA is a great way to describe it so
uh yeah I mean that's our Impressions on
cyberpunk 2077. uh Jake you also have
written thing up as well a written thing
yep which goes into more depth a little
more specific
um so if you want to check that out you
should do it yeah and uh for all things
Summer Games Fest stay here at GameStop
[Music]
transmission
hey everyone thank you so much for
joining us today and welcome to Bethesda
game studios you know we've been so
lucky over the decades to make the kind
of games that we love here and that's
thanks to all of you from the Elder
Scrolls The Fallout we love creating
these worlds and playing in them just as
much as you do and throughout all that
time we'd often talk about and dream up
the space game what if we could take
that feeling of being who you want to be
and exploring a new world but set it in
space where you weren't really Limited
in where you could go or what you could
do and that is Starfield obviously we've
come a long way since then with the
games we've built our technology and all
of us here in the studio we've done so
much together but well we've never tried
to make a game like this today you'll
get to hear from many on the team and
see so much of what we think makes our
game special so let's jump in and take a
look
[Music]
foreign
is our first new universe in over 25
years but it's still a Bethesda RPG
through and through where you step into
a new world and you get that feeling of
unlimited possibilities
but this time it's not just one world
it's over a thousand worlds
because the choice of where to go it's
not ours it's yours
and it wasn't until now that we had the
technology to create it
from the rocks at your feet to the
mountains in the distance
to the people and creatures that live in
these worlds
that isn't just a backdrop that moon is
actually there orbiting the planet yes
you can visit it too
technically simulate the Galaxy around
you
our next Generation lighting model uses
real-time Global illumination to light
the world based on the type of star and
the makeup of the planet's atmosphere
[Music]
we also have an all-new animation system
and of course you can play it in third
person
and you can play it in first person
we love exploration and rewarding it but
you do explore differently in this game
given its scale
that usually involves exploring an area
you've landed in
you can collect resources
do a mission and maybe even stumble upon
something unexpected
good
foreign
we do love stuff and all of the items
allowing you to pick everything up and
you can view all that in your data menu
this is the hub for everything you're
doing from your skills to your ship your
missions and your inventory we love to
pack a ton of detail in every object
from all of your weapons
to spacesuits
to food we just obsess over the details
and food we obsess over food
when you're done exploring you can walk
back or fast travel to your ship we have
Companions and crew you can take with
you I left vosco here back at my ship
welcome back Captain Howard and he can
even say your name let's head out
[Music]
our mission was to convey the Wonder and
Majesty of space exploration to evoke
the Romance of the golden age of early
space flight and we've been referring to
this approach as NASA Punk this means a
design language where the tech is
advanced yet still looks grounded and
relatable for us it's a contrast that's
where the visual interest is obviously
the NASA which is the rigid pod function
over style and then Punk which is all
about Style
you can see that visual style coming
through in your ship your ship is your
home for you and your crew and like many
of the spaces in our game it has a
slightly retro and analog touch a bit of
low-fi rather than sci-fi where
everything is well used worn and lived
in alrighty what's the plan captain
this is your star map it starts with the
planet you're currently on
you can see all of its info and
resources you can choose a landing spot
or fast travel to known locations
backing out further you can view all the
planets in the system obviously the game
is big and it's here you can see planets
that have key locations missions or life
on them versus the many planets that are
Barren but resource heavy
zoom out even further to see all the
systems in this part of the Galaxy
here you can plot a course to ones that
are light years away this uses your
ship's grab drive to fold space and jump
to these systems and you will need to
upgrade your shipping skills if you want
to jump to the most distant ones but for
now we'll plot a course to the Alpha
Centauri system where we can find the
city of New Atlantis
foreign
course while we scan your ship's cargo
[Music]
scan complete you are cleared for
landing at new Atlantis
[Music]
as soon as you land in a city like new
Atlantis your eyes are guided upwards to
just these boundless vast buildings it's
the biggest city we've ever made not
just in size but also in the amount of
custom art
crowds and quests
so the main focus when we're designing a
city is obviously what supports the
story we try and tell as many small
stories as possible this is a colony war
memorial it's a few moments of gameplay
that make the space feel like it's full
of real characters that are going about
their day-to-day lives it's paralyzed if
you really stop and think about it buddy
it's coffee it's also where your
adventure with constellation begins
[Music]
foreign
we have a lot to talk about by the time
you meet them constellation is sort of
seen as this mythical group most people
don't even know they exist anymore
they're the last true explorers in the
galaxy and they're trying to find the
answers to some of Humanity's biggest
questions
so alien and I'm certain one of them
reached out and spoke to you
yeah
the artifact if you could place it on
the table here
oh my God look at how it's coming
together that means
set built by an intelligence outside the
settled systems it's definitely an
Eclectic cast of characters you've got
Sarah Morgan the ex-soldier and
adventurer now constellations leader
Mateo the Theologian who believes that
there's definitely something else out
there Noel the gifted scientist and
Sarah Morgan's Protege and Walter a very
successful businessman in the settled
systems and constellations financier
anything goes as long as you have the
money there's also Vlad the ex-pirate
Sam Coe the former Space Cowboy and
baron you know what I hate about these
Pirates
completely resistant to my otherwise
irresistible charm
the journey you take with constellation
is just the first that many you'll
embark on the settled systems is home to
all kinds of different stories people
and Adventures for you to uncover
[Music]
the United Colonies is where you'll find
new Atlantis the first major human
settlement in space
people who live here value law
discipline and the legacy of humanity
they consider themselves the true
children of Earth you ever think of
joining up with a Vanguard of the United
Colonies even get your UC citizenship
new Atlantis isn't the only city within
the United Colonies
the city of Sedonia on Mars to this day
serves as the largest Mining facility
for the United Colonies
beyond the United Colonies reach you
might find yourself in a much more wild
and independent Coalition of star
systems
[Music]
this is Freestar Collective space
capital of the Freestar Collective is
Aquila City
the stone route inn is an Aquila City
fixture
Ranger relies on judgment and intuition
to do what's best for the people
neon started out as a fishing platform
but is now known throughout the cell
systems as a pleasure City where almost
anything goes if you've got morality
issues this definitely isn't the job for
you
[Music]
ryugen is hiring the best and brightest
of today for our future tomorrow
everyone has been chewed up and ground
up by Neon try not to get yourself
killed alright
outside the bounds of civilized space
there are still plenty of unclaimed
systems to explore but these areas are
also home to the most hostile factions
in the galaxy
the Great Serpent hungers all heathens
shall be made Dust In Time
a new face this is the face of a brave
Runner here to challenge the Red Mile
they think the Galaxy is theirs they are
wrong it belongs to the Crimson Fleet it
always has
[Music]
in Starfield we're pushing our cities
and settlements further than we ever
have before it's all there waiting for
you a slice of Humanity's future
so ready to get out there
[Music]
throughout the Galaxy there are so many
things to see and stories to experience
but the most important story is the one
that you tell
I'm the type of person who spends hours
in character creation and I think people
are going to be really excited when they
see all of the improvements we've made
one of the biggest overhauls was done
through our character generation system
we scanned a wide range of faces from
different age groups and ethnicities and
by mixing and matching out that data we
were able to create highly detailed and
diverse characters
we use that exact system to create all
the characters and NPCs you're going to
see in the game so any character you see
almost always is a character you could
make yourself
hey come on come on okay take it easy
you were out cold uh no physical damage
mentally the jury's still out
you know who you are new recruit for
Argos extractors ring any bells
any of this look familiar
you start your character creation
Journey as though you're cycling through
employee records you'll pick from a
lineup of 40 presets and that'll be your
starting point
your journey from there can be as
detailed or as quick as you want it to
be this new system has more to offer
than ever before
it's also the simplest character
Generations this we've ever had we let
the player get as close as possible to
make whatever they want with the various
facial morphs you can blend together the
thermostatic and makeup blemishes scars
piercings teeth settings it's a lot but
I think it's the most fun to use
character creation is more than just how
you look this is also where you start to
decide who you want to be that's where
backgrounds come in
backgrounds give you a bit of backstory
and starts you out with three basic
skills
from Chef to Dusty you know the crew
still has a betting pool about which
restaurant critic you must have crossed
to wind up here what's great about
backgrounds is you never know when yours
is going to come in handy you could be
in the middle of a fancy restaurant
talking to some guy and suddenly you
learn he needs a beast hunter to help
track down a monster fine I probably
should stick to professionals anyway
given what happened the last time we're
also giving you the option to customize
your build even further by letting you
pick up the three traits traits are
completely optional and they come with
their own advantages and disadvantages
your biggest fan
to join your crew and it'll give you
gifts if you're willing to put up with
this constant commentary I can't believe
I get to stand near you
[Music]
my favorite trait is kid stuff you have
to pay some credits to support your
parents but they're very sweet and it's
really fun to go visit them honey we got
ourselves a visitor oh my God I came
across some hostile zealots in space but
because I had chosen a treat that made
me the same religion as them I was able
to get by without any issues
[Music]
there's another great one that gives you
a damage Buff when your health is low
but mercenaries will randomly show up
and try to kill you
no matter what you choose there will be
plenty of ways for you to tell your
story and if you want to remove a trait
there are ways to do that too what a
view
It's A Feast for the eyes off we go
another
[Music]
we'll let you discover that on your own
oh
once you've built the perfect character
that's when your journey can really
begin
we took what we loved about skills and
perks from our previous games and put
them together to create an all new skill
system
each time you level up you get a skill
point which can be used to unlock or
rank up skills
ranks are unlocked by completing
challenges associated with that skill
[Music]
become increasingly difficult as you
work your way to higher ranks
foreign with our five different skill
trees and four ranks per skill there's a
lot to choose from
[Music]
sociology skill because it lets you mind
control aliens
[Music]
boost pack out of the gate I'm boost
packing everywhere
xing out my physical tree so I can get
neuro strikes and just punch my way
through combat
that one's a lot of fun
invest in the skills that suit your play
style
very much a stealth player so I'm out
there pickpocketing everyone
my favorite part about being stealthy
slowly creeping through vents like
you're in a movie
and then jumping out and springing on
people
[Music]
whenever possible I like to talk my way
through situations these areas off
limits
fine I'll issue you an access card I'm
more of a run and Gun player
I like doing the death from above thing
where I'd boost pack over guys and I
throw landmines at them
you're gonna pay for that
I like blowing stuff up
[Music]
exploration is a key aspect of all our
games
in Starfield there are full star systems
with new life resources and Adventures
[Music]
our team worked hard to strike a balance
between fun and realism
we study data from NASA and a multitude
of other sources to help us make the
world feel believable
from the way we approached planetary
atmospheres to the way we place biomes
based on the planet's distance from the
Sun
once we had created a grounded world we
could start looking at all the things
that make that world fun
when you leave a planet and head into
space
you'll be navigating asteroid Fields
having chance meetings with interesting
strangers dog fighting in space and
exploring derelict ships
[Music]
it's all out there
ultimately it's about rewarding your
curiosity because whether it's on the
surface of a planet the alleys of a city
or the vastus of space
you never know what you'll find
[Music]
space exploration is possible thanks to
your ship your ship is almost like
having another character or home you can
make all your own I think you'll be
blown away by the amount of stuff you
can do
you can buy a ship I'm sure you can find
something you like customize and upgrade
that ship
and hire a crew to keep it up and
running
[Music]
starts in spaceports
every Spaceport has a ship technician
where you can purchase sell and modify
ships anything I can help you with
maybe you start off with a speedy
fighter that's perfect for bounty
hunting
then you might round out your ship
roster with a hulking space freighter to
run cargo missions or even do a little
smuggling
for now though we're going to take our
starting ship the frontier
and make some changes
you can customize and upgrade everything
you see here
and you have two ways to do that
you can quickly upgrade individual
systems like your weapons or Shields
or you can deep dive and enter the
shipbuilder mode here you can change
anything from the systems to the look
and layout
adding a new habitat module can give you
more room for crew
adding cowling can change your ship's
overall silhouette
an improved grav Drive allows for longer
distance space jobs
you can even fully customize your paint
job to get the exact look you want
the parts you choose to build with don't
just affect your ship's stats
they'll also affect what you can do
inside your ship
you can have modules for crafting
or for storing and displaying your
weapons
starfield's in-game ship manufacturers
bring their own look and feel to every
piece of your ship
from living quarters to cargo holds mess
halls and control rooms
thank you
our modified Frontier is a practical
ship but with a little creativity your
ship can look like almost anything you
want
ways of customizing
platypus as I called it
where I had like a giant tail to it
[Music]
and we've done spiders we've done mechs
so it's really whatever your imagination
is
[Music]
and while you can build your home Among
the Stars the way you want to you're
probably not the only person who will
call your ship home
[Music]
ready to lift off when you are captain
engines ready
Frontier is fueled and ready captain
some of the members of constellation can
join you on your journey these
companions can serve on your crew and
they'll always be there when you travel
we'll be traveling together until we
either find an artifact or this lead
Runs Dry
each companion comes with their own
valuable skills for your ships and
outposts
as well as unique quest lines eventually
some friendships might blossom into
romance I don't know that I've ever
really loved anyone
except you and if you're looking for a
little extra help on your ship you can
always hire additional crew at
spaceports got any room on your ship for
someone like me
you'll also meet potential crew members
out in the world still think there might
be a spot for me on your ship I gotta
get off this rock
assigned crew to your ship or outposts
and their unique skills will affect how
they run
and just like companions most crew
members can lend a hand in the field
take Bosco for instance
these designed around the core basics of
a NASA machine please avoid getting shot
you might die I still want to give it
almost a humanoid personality so I
elongated the limbs this tends to make
him feel more human-like and give him a
little personality it is a shame
exploration requires so much bloodshed
using the ship building tools and crew
selection features in Starfield you'll
be able to build and Captain the ship of
your dreams
[Music]
let's take to the sky
we're putting you in the cockpit of your
very own spaceship and telling you that
you can do pretty much anything and that
is really cool for us as Developers
flight should be exciting and dangerous
and you should feel like you're in
complete control every step of the way
we've extended that sense of control to
ship combat it's not about just hitting
your triggers to fire your weapons
complex dance between your piloting
skills and our power allocation system
boosting power to your engines will make
your ship faster
powering up the ground dries will
shorten the amount of time it takes
before you can make a jump
moving your power to your weapons and
shields means you're ready for a fight
should always be on your toes because
you're not alone out there
[Music]
unlocking the targeting control system
skill will allow you to zero in on
specific subsystems of the ship you
target
after destroying an enemy ship you can
loot The Remains from your cockpit
you can always turn any ship that
engages you into scrap
but you could also take a more personal
approach by docking with the Enemy
vessel and boarding their ship
once you've taken control of an enemy
ship it's yours
at your Fleet and retrieve it at any
Spaceport
but space is way more than fighting for
your life
just like when you're PlanetSide there
are plenty of sights to see and stops to
make on the way to your next adventure
like these massive star yards
Walk The Halls talk to the crew maybe
get talked into buying a whole new ship
a civilian in moistaya let's see about
getting you a proper ship one worthy of
you maybe you'll dock with a gigantic
Battleship like the UC vigilance
foreign
or rub elbows with the Galaxy's wealthy
Elite on a cruise ship fit for the Stars
there are plenty of personal encounters
to be had as well you can hail any ship
you come across to trade swap info or
maybe even commit an act of piracy let's
do this when I'm playing I generally go
crazy
um I definitely go like the more piracy
routes I want to take over ships I'm
going to board ships I'm like this is
now mine I steal all these sandwiches
and put them you know in my cargo hold
that I have specifically for sandwiches
I don't want to play the hero but I want
to go out and just start taking things
from people as quickly as possible
some strangers might be looking for a
little human Connection in the darkness
of space
hello stranger I just finished cooking
up some food if you want to come on over
just pop on by
some of the best moments are the ones
you discover on your own
the thing I love most about Starfield is
that it is a Bethesda game through and
through it's really about going to
strange new places meeting interesting
people and getting sidetracked on zany
Adventures then realizing two hours
later that you're involved in a
completely new story you'll
feel so present here it's in our Random
Encounters it's in our handcrafted
quests
and it feels so cool to play it and just
make your own path in this universe
there are over a thousand planets out
there just waiting for you to visit
we want you to feel like explorers
breaking ground on new planets exploring
every inch of a mostly untouched Galaxy
[Music]
we want you to feel hopeful
we want you to feel this sense of awe
and wonder
and sometimes a little fear
we're giving you a massive playground
and a ton of toys and just setting you
free
[Music]
foreign
you so much stuff but we thought we'd
just take a little break and show you
something a little bit different you
know we put so much detail into our game
worlds and we love the opportunity to
bring that into the real world with our
Collector's Editions and for this game
uh we've done a watch it is the
constellation explorers watch this is
the watch that you actually get in the
game that acts as part of your HUD where
it's the compass and then environmental
information it connects to your phone to
give you notifications and other
information and we've also designed this
really cool case that it comes with
eastvan
yeah we really took as much care and
designed as cases we did to watch our
attention to detail and to gain totally
translates to this inspired by the cases
that the astronauts used during the
Apollo era to bring back samples from
the moon it's got an intricate locking
mechanism authentic heavy comes with a
constellation patch NATO strap and the
overall functionality and believability
of this as something that would exist in
the world in the Starfield universe hey
take this you'll find it very useful out
there and it even tells the time
we actually have something else now that
we're part of Xbox we get to work with
the amazing people on the Xbox Hardware
team and together we have created this
custom limited edition Starfield
controller it's awesome it is now you
know our favorite controller we love
this because it's inspired by the actual
controls of your spaceship
and not only that
we've created the first ever custom
headset with Xbox and this is a perfect
pairing with that controller
departure
[Music]
in every one of our games we always put
so much care into all those little
details that breathe life into our
worlds
but Starfield isn't just a Bethesda game
studios world it's a Bethesda game
studios Galaxy
so why go this big with Starfield
because we want to give you freedom on a
galactic level
the freedom to experience both the
exciting planets
and The Quiet Ones
scanning a planet before you land is a
great way to get a sneak peek at the
available resources you can use for
crafting building and customizing I
think what's cool about this whole
system that we we generate the planet
itself as a procedural content but the
handcrafted content itself comes as the
player Explorer
our system builds a planet as the player
approaches it and we stitch together the
luck of terrain after that we have the
system that adds interested locations
for the player to explore creatures to
encounter
or and plans to pick up
it allows us to add that touch of
environmental storytelling that Bethesda
is known for
teachers have been disrupting our
experiments their habitat isn't far from
here if you could take care of them for
us we would be in your debt so even if
your friends were to visit the same
planet that you had you would have a
different story to tell
[Music]
take this guy down
it's completely up to you how you want
to interact with each planet whether you
want to explore and see what you can
find
Harvest resources and be on your way
or simply take in the views
with the help of your scanner you'll
chart the Uncharted and discover exotic
wildlife
if you have the skills you can even
figure out that certain creatures and
plants you can build an outpost and
produce resources from those plants and
animals you can get experience and
rewards for fully surveying planets and
fully surveying a whole system
[Music]
we're concepting these creatures we
really wanted to think of them as
natural to the environment we didn't
want alien monsters we wanted native
wildlife
something you've never seen before
when it comes to our exteriors when the
sun moves all that light is calculated
in real time through the atmosphere
our biggest goal for lighting with
Starfield was to make the game feel more
filmic to use lighting and color to
really make it feel more cinematic
oh
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
anyway
[Applause]
[Music]
s
foreign
between Solomon and Johnny I'd like to
think I'm always an angel
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me today
like
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
foreign
welcome to the Xbox games showcase
extended my name is Tina amini and I'm
here to dive a little bit more into the
games you saw at our recent Xbox game
showcase
showcase featured 27 ambitious games all
coming to Xbox games like clockwork
Revolution from nxl entertainment Fable
from playground games and from our
partners Star Wars Outlaws from Ubisoft
massive and collaboration with lucasfilm
games and kunitsugami half of the
Goddess from Capcom today we'll take a
closer look at some other games from our
showcase lineup and introduce you to
some more games too we've got the game
director of a vowed from Obsidian
Entertainment breaking down the game's
trailer and the game director of Hi-Fi
Rush from Tango Gameworks is here to
tell us about their newest update you'll
also hear from Sarah Bond Head of the
gaming ecosystem Organization for Xbox
who will tell us more about a program to
bring games from underrepresented
developers with unique Visions to Xbox
and Game Pass and we may just have a few
other fun guests in store for you too so
stay tuned but first let's check out the
Rainy Streets and Sinister markets of
cyberpunk 27 27 Phantom Liberty
hello everyone I'm really excited to
welcome you to this exclusive Xbox store
over Black Market one of the locations
in Dogtown that you are going to be able
to explore in cyberpunk 2077 Phantom
Liberty
as you can see Dogtown welcomes you with
an open arms
a location where you as a player as a
mercenary you can obtain unique
cyberware and weapons things that you
cannot find anywhere in this world
dog town is a part of night City but has
its own very distinct look and Vibe it's
outside of the jurisdiction of mcpd
attracting all kinds of eccentrics and
dangerous characters
radical mods
do anything like that on a non-male
stroller
check this out
for this year
we have put a lot of work into making
the world feel more alive small scenes
secrets to find Easter eggs make this
place feel more vibrant and more
believable
but what's inescapable in Dogtown is
Kurt Hansen Kurt is a leader of Burgess
militia who rules dockdown of an iron
fist you've come to the right place
and dog town I keep your business safe
as long as you abide by my rules they're
really nice guy as you can see
the black market also is a place where
you can find new illegal weapons and
goods they are some of the most powerful
items in the world but are often much
more dangerous to use and use cyber
capacity system which leads you to push
your body to the Limit and give you new
abilities to deliver more thrilling
gameplay experiences like the air Dash
or the ability to see the enemies
through the walls or change your
appearance to lose the Heat
August is the authorities of Dogtown and
they are more dangerous than ncpd when
you as a player commit crimes in Dogtown
they are the guys who are going to chase
you we have completely overhauled the
police system
all these actions are more believable
Dynamic and diverse the team has been
working passionately to deliver you more
deeper and meaningful experience and I
really cannot wait for you to find out
more this September
see you in Dogtown
we're not done talking about CD projekt
Red's next dive into the story between V
and Johnny just yet in fact we're here
with the voice and stylings of Johnny
silverhand Keanu Reeves himself welcome
thank you it's a pleasure to be here
likewise well Phantom Liberty introduces
us to an entirely new location in night
City it's called Dogtown it's this
devastated place it's controlled by a
militia but I think you know more about
it than I do so how would you describe
it to players night city has its own
kind of
levels to it and I think dog town is
kind of going down to a darker place
um
it's dystopian
it has attention to it and
this under current of kind of violence
you know like and struggle
you know can I swear yeah shit's gone
down
in dog town oh I like that tagline yeah
and it's just you know I mean hopefully
it'll be fun for people to uh
to play there
it's hard to believe that there's an
underbelly to the underbelly yes that is
night city right yeah I'm a little
scared but in a good way no it's a good
way I mean we're all kind of drawn to
we're all Moths To The Flame aren't we
and there's a lot of
flame and dark time well if anyone could
take it on it's V so that certainly
gives me the confidence yeah Visa
Survivor exactly oh yeah you know and we
just saw a tour of Dogtown too so we got
a little bit of that Ambiance and we can
see what the environment is like people
are getting beat up it's not good it's
me it's not the friendliest place to be
you gotta you gotta be prepared for it
truly yeah but in our tour we also hear
a recording from a colonel Kurt Hansen
who's this guy because he seems pretty
dangerous too yeah that guy no I'm sorry
I can't say that my inner Johnny came
out I think that's good we know the tone
now yeah well I mean he's ex-military
military too ruthless power hungry
manipulative and Johnny doesn't like him
I could see that it's I mean night City
in general is the kind of place that
breeds that kind of character yeah let's
take a step back let's talk about Johnny
as a person instead of this horrible
person known as Colonel Kurt Hanson I
don't know about this guy but people
like Johnny and I think it's interesting
because we know him to be opinionated
he's radical we've seen that in
cyberpunk 2077 in the main campaign but
as we get to know him he's got a
sensitive side too he can actually be
quite caring oh that's what makes it so
much fun he is outspoken he is a little
grumpy and he has a right to be he's
been used he's been abused he's been
abandoned and I think that through that
kind of hardness of his outside there is
a vulnerability to him and I think
what's great about it is I I get to play
that character in so many different ways
and so arrange him in his school
especially for the play
these moments in flashbacks you start to
and he's a product of his upbringing
truly of his surrounding well unless I
get carried away I mean I mean we could
start talking about nature and nurture
I'm sorry I keep dropping into Johnny
but uh
um
yeah I like I like his anger
I like his passion I like what he stands
for he's
he's really just looking for a fair shot
and I I love that he's kind of going
through music that is an artist side to
him and
you know I got some great speeches
there's all these moments with Johnny
where a tiny little thing you know
elicits this really fun response you can
flip him off and he double Birds you
back like I love those kind of moments
or Rock I think another interesting lens
of looking at him as we get into Phantom
Liberty is his Dynamic with Solomon Reed
so what can you tell me about Johnny's
relationship with Idris elba's character
I think Solomon has some things in
common with Johnny in the sense of the
military the sense of being used abused
um you know it's in the title right
they're fighting for a liberty
you know Solomon's kind of trying to
reclaim his life
you know and Johnny's doing the same
thing you know it's cyberpunk 2077 so it
might start off as a revenge and it
might end as Revenge but I think
sometimes he feels like he's lashing out
at the wind
you know and I think Solomon
has been living out in the continent the
desert of his life right kind of hiding
and harboring yeah but I think he also
has that kind of soft and hard side to
him as well
yeah
so as somebody who's very familiar with
Thrillers because you've started in a
few
what do you think about Phantom Liberty
makes for a good spy Thriller in
particular
the quest to understand what's going on
so and and the kind of scavenger hunt of
information
the mystery the double crossing what is
true what's fiction what can you count
on you can't count on anything that is
really kind of Amplified
well thank you so much for coming out to
another Xbox presentation you've got a
lot of fans out there in the Xbox
community so I think I can speak for all
of us and say we really appreciate you
showing up here today oh well thank you
yeah
well before I close things out I love
your help here at Keanu how do you think
Johnny would end this interview right
now
well there's a lot of ways you could do
that
but uh Tina pleasure to meet you oh is
that how Johnny would do it yeah oh
thank you Johnny
such a pleasure to have you I thought
you were going to kick down the camera
or something so yeah
he's respectful you know you're a good
egg oh thank you you too and I'll see
you out there again soon
[Music]
right here
oh I'm so sorry for dragging you all
into this
[Music]
[Laughter]
the world you think you live in
doesn't exist
[Music]
and if you get a glimpse behind the
scenery the stage cry
you will discover nothing but darkness
and once perceived it will swallow you
whole
I'm in a race against this Darkness a
race to locate an ancient ruin a tower
of unspeakable power I need the best of
the best
They're All Dead
so I'll use you
Scout clothes
thieves
Cutthroats the best of the worst
[Music]
foreign
you're going to help me save the world
[Music]
when it comes to RPG Studios Obsidian
Entertainment is among the very best
from Fallout New Vegas and the outer
worlds to Star Wars Knights of the Old
Republic II and pentiment obsidian games
have placed their stamp on the genre
joining us today for a closer look at
about is game director Carrie Patel
Carrie I am so excited to have you here
we just saw this big reveal of a vowed
and there's so many little bits of
information in there that I want to dig
out and pick your brain around but
before we get into all that I'm assuming
that you don't need to have played
pillars one or two to really get into a
vowed you're absolutely right you don't
need to have played pillars one or two
you can come to the world of avowed
fresh we want this to be a welcoming
experience to new players but if you are
a returning fan there are some
recognizable tidbits for people who have
played pillars one or two can you tease
any more of just those General
connections to the universe and no Major
Spoilers of course yeah there are a
couple returning characters that players
might recognize from dead fire in
particular players who have played the
original games will recognize some of
the parts of the world and some of the
factions the adirin Empire plays pretty
heavily into the world of a vowed so all
of that will be familiar to returning
players we do start to see some of that
pillars Universe now in the avowed
setting which is really exciting and
it's looking amazing so far but can you
confirm one thing for me are we still in
aora we're still in aora and
specifically we're in a region called
The Living lands so again returning
pillars fans will recognize the living
lands as this otherworldly Frontier it's
very remote It's relatively unknown it's
this very dramatic landscape full of all
of these different valleys with these
unique biomes and creatures just a
really unique visual perspective and
it's a wonderful Frontier Z Spot that's
set for adventure there's a lot that's
undiscovered and so that's the part of
aora that we're introducing players to
in a vowed and we also see a character
talking to us in the trailer he seems
like he might be a companion because
that would be a very obsidian thing to
do so what's going on with that yes this
is Kai and he's one of the first
companions you made in the game he's an
amawa that's one of the unique species
of the world of aora and Kai is a
character brings a balance of this
really battle-hardened perspective he's
seen a lot he's served as a soldier and
a mercenary but he also has a really
unique sense of humor so he brings the
spirit of levity and camaraderie to the
party as well and as he's talking to us
he's also kind of conveying well he's
straight up saying that he's afraid of
you and your abilities but it's not like
the heroes are the only powerful beings
in this universe so I'm curious what
that means for who we are as the player
character are we a watcher again like in
Pillars one and two or maybe we have
some connections to the spirit realm and
beyond that gives us these terrifying
abilities so you're not a watcher this
time but you do have a unique Soul
connection to the world that gives you a
connection to the living lens and to
some of the more mysterious forces that
work there the player is also being sent
as an Envoy of the adiran Empire and so
they come with both a very mysterious
Aura but also a certain sense of
political urgency Kai also mentions a
plague that's another bit of detail that
we get within the trailer see a very
concerning growth on a lot of the
creatures in the world what can you tell
us about this plague I can't say too
much just yet except that it is a unique
Soul plague that is devouring the living
lands and part of the player's Mission
and being sent here is to investigate
and try to stop it we also saw a lot of
combat in the trailer and we see dual
wielding pistols we see spells we see
swords we see just a ton of abilities a
lot that actually is really reminiscent
of the pillars Universe too but those
were isometric top-down view games and a
vowed as a first person game so how did
the team approach that same kind of
fantasy combat but in the first person
for about so we wanted to take that same
depth and breadth of play Styles and
combat abilities and player fantasies
where you can play someone who's very
magically attuned more traditional
fighter or Ranger and really invest in
whatever play style is most appealing to
you personally we wanted to take that
depth and breadth and translate it into
a first-person experience where you can
feel the visceral nature of the attacks
feel the dynamism and the momentum of
those attacks and you're executing them
and that means including a range of
options like as you noted dual wielding
pistols which is one of my favorites
because you don't see that often in
fantasy RPGs but also traditional sword
and board a whole host of magical
abilities a lot of things it'll be both
a little bit familiar but hopefully new
to players as well and I've got one more
question for you because I know the
audience is going to want to know this
one but just how big is this game so
it's going to be roughly comparable to
something like Knights of the Old
Republic 2 or the outer worlds it is set
up as a series of interconnected open
zones that players can explore at their
own pace you can invest in discovering
every nook and cranny in the world
discovering every secret finding every
side quest meeting every character or
you can have a much more focused
experience and it's really up to players
and how much time they want to spend in
the living lands but I'm hopeful that
they're going to spend a lot of time
with us once a valve releases well Count
Me In is one of those players because I
definitely want to read and hear every
line of dialogue everything everyone has
to tell me and discover every inch of
the living lands well thank you again so
much for being here Carrie this has been
so insightful and fun thank you Tina
this has been a pleasure that was just a
taste of what you can expect from
Obsidian Entertainment when a vowed
lands next year on Xbox PC and Game Pass
[Music]
thank you
foreign
negative
severeign
foreign
good evening
question
mark
foreign
be the first descendants
when we were wrapping up Banner Saga we
were really talking about what is it we
want to do next
we earnestly started with the idea
of making a game that was hopeful that
it was a Triumph of the human Spirit
something that had a lot of Replay
ability something that you can
um really explore for for a long time
there are different worlds that we want
to explore
towerborne is that game
towerborn is a fast-paced action RPG
it's a co-op game you can play online
you can play it on a couch with your
friends and family everybody's moving
through the world map together as the
players move out they start
breadcrumbing the storyline that is
being told here from the world map you
go into fun fast combat
you come out of that with resources and
crafting items and with all their new
Loop they can go back to the belfry
The Belfry is the Players Safe Haven and
Humanity's Safe Haven the player can
customize their appearance their Loadout
talk to all these different NPCs the
world itself is a mix of 3D in in 2D we
definitely wanted to have that kind of
beautiful background that you see in
animated movies
powerborn is all about Humanity's last
chance at survival humanity is clinging
to Hope and clinging to this Tower
it is your mission to try to hold the
forces of Darkness at Bay to give
Humanity a chance at survival
the most important thing about the
gameplay is just it's just fun and it
kind of just Amplified its fun the
moment you added another player all of
the players can build their character in
a way that's specific to them just turns
into this back and forth exploration
like let's try to do this one combo and
then let's see if you can do a follow-up
from a couch Co-op perspective that's
just really fun because there's not too
many couch co-op games anymore
[Music]
hoping in five years from now it's in a
place that I never even would have
thought of it's a seasonal game which is
different for us players can expect a
new storyline with new quests new biomes
we'll be rolling out new gear new
monsters new bosses expanding on the
content in a in a continuous organic way
so it just becomes a living world
[Music]
stoic we decided let's just make games
that we feel strongly about and we want
to play we had to find the right
relationship with a publisher and I
think we found that with Xbox they've
enabled us to make the game that we want
to make here
I earnestly cannot wait for the
community to see the game that we're
rolling at here towerborne is I I really
believe something unique
[Music]
there's that Roar again
what the hell is that thing
oh
hello I'm John Rush art director for
fall
I hope you enjoyed the world premiere of
the trailer for our once in a blue moon
update coming June 20th free to play for
anyone who owns Fallout 76.
blue moon has risen over the hills of
Appalachia bringing with it a ton of
great new content for players
that includes new Cryptids like the blue
devil and ogwa to threaten the progress
of the Blue Ridge Caravan company
we've also got two new public events
both of which give you a chance to earn
Caravan encrypted themed Rewards
defend the middle Mountain pit stop from
waves of monstrous creatures safe and
sound
and thwart a horde of crazed cultists
and be subverted
season 13 we've also got a new
scoreboard called shoot for the stars
celebrates the stars of the Silver
Screen
and gives you a chance to earn Cinema
themed Rewards
[Music]
and we're not done yet
next year we're taking players to
Atlantic City
where they'll gamble on the fates of new
factions for the opportunity to win big
do your part in helping the Blue Ridge
Caravan come
and earn rewards along the way once in a
blue moon is coming June 20th Appalachia
is coming at you we'll see you there
[Applause]
[Music]
what's this
thank you
what happened now
[Music]
foreign
we've just seen a new trailer for
updates coming to HiFi Rush called
arcade challenge update no joke there's
literally exclamation points in there
that's not just me so here to explain
that and more about the update is game
director John Johannes welcome to
Showcase extended John really glad to be
here exclamation points
they have to be in there yeah it feels
the style it's style yeah the style
thing well Hi-Fi Rush is such a stylish
game in general I think that's one of
the things that people really excitedly
pointed out when we Shadow dropped the
game in the developer direct earlier
this year but making a brand new IP is
always a bit of a risk your studio is
known for kind of scarier games like The
Evil Within and ghostwire Tokyo can't
deny that
um but yeah this type of game is
something I just always wanted to make
personally and I just thought music and
action work so well together and after I
had finished working on the evil within
two it just felt like the right time to
try something new and our studio has
always been about just making fun games
it doesn't have to be about a certain
genre we're not about making one
specific thing unfortunately there's
plenty more of that content to come
because we just saw an absolutely
jam-packed trailer so I'd love for your
help in breaking down all the details
all the stuff going into this update
sure there's a lot so bear with me
everything in this mode is unlockable
once you finish the game and you'll
unlock an arcade cabinet in your hideout
and by accessing it you get two new
modes one is called BPM Rush mode which
takes the gameplay up to like higher
speeds than we've ever done in the main
game and the other is called power up
Tower up which is a new sort of
randomized spin on the Rhythm Tower mode
that we have in the original game and
included in this mode are five new
original songs to play do as well as two
brand new enemies and then there's
special attacks and this whole meta
system for unlocking upgrades and
rewards and that's what I can think of
right now I love that there's so much to
to unpack there but let's rewind let's
talk about just BPM rush for now it was
described in the trailer as effectively
Hi-Fi Russia's equivalent of a turbo
mode can you explain that a little bit
more yeah early on the team was like how
fast can we go and in the game we kind
of settle that you know about a Max 160
BPM but this mode really takes it up to
200 BPM but we sort of ease you in there
it's a gradual upgrade until it
eventually gets so fast you just gotta
sort of think on your feet and naturally
react to the Rhythm in the combat of the
game I personally love that there's a
lot of accessibility settings in the
game too makes it so that you can adjust
the game to your own Comfort level but
this is a post game challenge it's meant
for when you've gotten into the rhythm
of the game so I'm curious if you have
any pointers on as far as how to tackle
that challenge as an action game I think
a lot of people want that sort of next
level challenge another way to use their
abilities in a new type of environment
this mode does that by putting you at
the high speed but we also have multiple
difficulties we have an easy mode for
people who want to experience what
that's like but maybe are not in tune
with that sort of high difficulty that's
accompanied with this stuff but then we
have a casual normal mode as well and
then we have after beating those modes
we can unlock an ex mode which takes up
to a hard level where damage is
Multiplied and keeps you at that high
BPM throughout the entire time but there
already was a post game challenge when
Hi-Fi Rush launched it was the Rhythm
Tower mode you mentioned that briefly
earlier that's the one where you face
just increasingly different difficult
combat so how has that evolved with the
power of power up mode so the Rhythm
Tower mode was kind of like a very
curated experience and while it was very
challenging you can prepare go in and
sort of customize your character know
what you're getting into and in this
mode we flip it to the almost opposite
end chai starts off downgraded we
actually remove all your abilities and
you have to earn them back by fighting
waves of randomized enemy sets and after
every wave of enemies you get to choose
from a series of power-ups that can
gradually increase your stats each of
these upgrades comes with either bonus
or negative modifiers as well to the
gameplay so you can take more risks or
less risks depending on which upgrades
you pick and again those upgrades are
randomized each level so really kind of
an understanding of the systems and not
quite Master them but have a good grasp
if you want to go in and come out on top
well as I mentioned earlier it was a
really packed trailer there was a lot of
information in there it's a chunky
update so what else have you got for us
because I feel like there's more on the
table there yeah so by playing in the
two modes you unlock these rewards to
these challenges that are connected to
these two modes and in those rewards are
things like accessories for chai and new
costumes for chai 808 and even as well
as fan favorite Corsica we have new
modes for the photo mode as well things
like new filters we have new poses for
the characters we have stickers you can
place on the photos Now and Then There
are some extra hidden secrets that we
don't want to give away right now which
uh as you know from our game we like to
hide in there and we like people to find
which is always fun and then in
conjunction with this release we're also
releasing a separate uh costume pack
which is a kind of take on what the
characters would look like if maybe this
game took place in a different time
period oh a little tease I like that and
there's some really fun fun looking
stuff in there so well thank you again
so much for coming out all the way from
Japan to Showcase extended John I'm
super glad to be here that's all we have
to share about the new update for Tango
Gameworks is Hi-Fi Rush coming soon now
it's time for for us to return to the
second era of Tamriel in the Elder
Scrolls online xenomax online Studios
debuted the trailer for their upcoming
expansion at Showcase and today they're
here to break that trailer down for us
let's hear what the team has to say
about the necron expansion for Elder
Scrolls Online
[Music]
hey everyone thank you so much for
watching the Xbox showcase I'm rich
Lambert the creative director on Elder
Scrolls online and I'm CJ greb I'm the
project art director for Elder Scrolls
Online
one of the really interesting things
about Elder Scrolls Online is it's
different than really any other game out
there it's not your typical level gated
world go anywhere you can explore in any
order you want to you really can hop in
at any moment play with anybody can play
any part of the game and any story
and of course I mean we're on Xbox game
pass you know the biggest open world RPG
on Xbox and if you're at all a fan of
Elder Scrolls
the places that you maybe have never
gone before in Elder Scrolls and do
things that you've never been able to do
there's so many different activities to
participate in housing
we've got lore hunting and Antiquities
right there's the Dungeons and the
trials and you can of course always
revisit lands that you've been to before
we've got Skyrim Morrowind yeah and
there are different times you know we're
almost a thousand years in the past
come in by yourself coming with friends
but don't worry that you're ever not
going to have something to do because
there are Adventures everywhere you go
we had an awesome trailer during the
Showcase
crumb Hermes Mora yeah what's it all
about rich Hamas Mora is this Daedric
god of knowledge he's not good he's not
evil he is just focused on cataloging
the world and collecting everything he
possibly can to study and what you kind
of see in the trailer is more a kind of
always on guard always looking over and
watching what's kind of going on and you
get to see some nostalgia in there as
well from the Dragonborn DLC in Skyrim
with the yellow green Skies vast Inky
sea the stacks of books I'll still never
forget the first time you showed us the
initial concepts for everything made out
of books I remember looking at that
going oh my God how are we going to do
it how is this gonna run
we always try to honor the past right
because when we go back to areas that
people who play Elder Scrolls games have
played they know these lands we want
them to feel like they're coming home
right but we have the chance to to add a
little into the mix
the art team was able to really play
with kind of cool unique monsters yeah
we were given some great places to go
for new monsters in the zone
we were looking at making a creature
that would kind of freeze you in Terror
as soon as you saw it and a creature
that has a deeper connection to the
overall story of The Zone we've also got
the tavani peninsula kind of the
Morrowind Vibe it's always fun to go
back to this part of Tamriel because
it's it's one of the most imaginative
and sort of like visually expressive
things that has ever been created for in
a little Scrolls world and then of
course necron City itself this ancient
city that you know is rumored to have
been built you know even before the
tribunal was even established right
being able to play with that and look at
that architecture in this ancient city
of the dead and you guys gave us a new
class to do The Arcanist draws their
powers from Hamas Mora we really
challenged ourselves and the team to
make something that didn't feel like
anything else that we have built
sounds amazing but when do we actually
get to play it necron launches on Xbox
June 20th and we can't wait for
everybody to get in there and see this
amazing content that we've created
thanks everyone for watching us during
the Showcase and watching us today lots
of exciting stuff coming for ESO in the
future we'll see you on Tamara
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
from a safe distance
congratulations
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
it's great to see the dedication from
the team at Capcom and how they're
building exoprimal in partnership with
the community
gaming has the power to immerse Us in
Worlds and perspectives we've never
otherwise experienced we can fight
dinosaurs transport to a dystopian
future explore the universe and conjure
magic and we get to do this together no
matter where we are on the planet the
language we speak what we look like or
our physical abilities
that is why it is both an absolute
imperative and an incredible opportunity
the games represent all of us
that is why we created the idea Xbox
developer acceleration program to help
underrepresented creators and stories in
the industry shine
we call it dap dap already includes more
than 100 emerging developers and they've
launched 30 incredible games like a
space for the Unbound validate
and HOA and there are many many more in
the works let's take a look at these
amazing games coming up next from ID and
Xboxes developer acceleration program
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I got a call from my good friend York
Newman the head of Microsoft flight
simulator he told me about this once in
a lifetime out of this world opportunity
so I'm here in Budapest the capital of
Hungary York he's around here somewhere
let's go find him
.org Hey Paris it's great to see you
great to see you thanks for coming to
Budapest of course what am I doing here
I tell you on the way we have a boat to
catch a boat yep we don't have a plane
nope come on Paris
[Music]
thank you
York what is this place what kind of
aircraft are you storing in here dude
it's much cooler than that
all right Paris are you ready for this
you know I'm ready for this all right
let's go
[Music]
welcome to the world of Dooms this is
incredible
come on I want you to meet someone
hey how's it going how are you man it's
good to see you I see you Paris I would
like to introduce Patrice Vermette
Academy award-winning production
designer of Dune it is very nice to meet
you I'm a huge fan of Dune now Patrice
can you tell me what is this place well
this is the warehouse where we actually
keep most of the props and the setback
elements that we used on doing part one
and part two
you know York how did all this get
started so it goes back to November 2021
Dune had just hit the movie theaters
worldwide and we got a car from
legendary and they had the idea that we
bring an ornessopter into Microsoft
flight simulator
and me being a lifelong science fiction
reader and fan a big huge fan of the
Frank Herbert books how could I say no
okay now it makes sense after seeing the
trailer at the Xbox showcase I
understand why you brought me here you
guys want to take a look because we
actually do have a couple of Ernie
thefters here if you want to see you
want to take a look that would be
awesome yeah let's do it all right let's
do it all right
[Music]
look at this it's a one-on-one wheel
size the one that's up there it's
amazing sure thank you the knee likes
things to be plausible so that's why
they were built to look military rugged
and stealth now here's the most
important question were they built to
fly
I've been asked that question a couple
of occasions uh no they don't fly they
are heavy they're 11 tons so you're you
have to get this working in the game how
did you do this in Flight soon yeah it
was actually interesting so in in
general ornithoptos can fly and do fly
this particular one given that it weighs
11 tons that's going to be a little bit
harder specifically because it's not
really doing the onus of the bird flap
it does oscillation of the blades and we
currently don't have the material
science to get the thrust and the lift
but on a rock is I think this is
absolutely possible that flights in we
made it work
Patrice we're here
can we go in absolutely all right let's
do it normally we'd go in through the uh
climbing up the landing gear but I guess
we'll do
yeah so what's cool about this Paris is
that all those buttons are actually
realistically hooked up to the system
Master engine switch what you're doing
there above those the red are basically
all the lights and as you notice
um it's all analog because in the world
of Doom there's no thinking machines
thinking machines have been illegal for
10 000 years that was actually
fascinating when we implemented it we
because it's a science fiction we
thought oh it's glass cockpits
everything is going to be computerized
like none of it is this is a very
practical helicopter almost like from
the 1960s so York in the first movie the
popular was able to do a lot of cool
moves and Maneuvers you're going to be
able to reproduce that in Flight Tim oh
yeah totally I mean the really cool
design that you guys came up with is
each blade is independently controlled
so each blade has its own lift and
thrust and that means you can go from a
really stable hover to a steep dive and
back to a Glide instantaneously I would
just say thank you that you designed
such an awesome and realistic machine
because that's what we do we bring
realistic machines to life but if you
want to see a little bit more about the
game design I have something for you
absolutely I'd love to see
all right so the setup for this
expansion is that you are a tradies
pilot on a rock is flying in order
here is what we built
but basically built this section of a
ruckus here's the capital city of alkene
here's a Botanical Garden we have that
as well and the first thing we do is we
train you up the fast take off fast
landing and then the Deep dive and then
we take you to some of the extreme
locations like above the cliff the hole
in the rock
the red Chasm you really have to show
your pilot skills and then towards the
end then there's a secret mission which
I can't talk about today but that
basically wraps up the experience it's
gonna be great super exciting hey it was
great to see you again
Paris
thank you for thank you so much for
having me
all right York
where to next
well I don't know what they eat on the
Rockets but this is Budapest and I hear
they have excellent goulash I know a
place let's go
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Liza p is a thrilling Souls like that
takes the story of Pinocchio turns its
on its head and sets it against the
Darkly elegant backdrop of The Bella
poke era
finally
we meet
we meet you were awakened by a
mysterious voice
you must adapt yourself and your weapons
to face Untold untangle the
unfathomable secrets of the city's
Elites and choose whether to confront
predicaments with the truth
or weave lies to overcome them on the
journey to find yourself
you are able to create your own weapon
through the combination of these blades
and handles but the hundreds of possible
combinations with different respective
appearances performances attack motions
and patterns
each and every blade and handle has this
distinctive Fable Arts Fable Arts is a
special combat skill that can be casted
by consuming Fable slots Fable slots can
be charged again through combat select
your own special skills to Vanquish your
enemies the legion arm is a prosthetic
on P's left arm the legion arm can
exhibit special abilities by consuming
the legion gauge providing you an
Eclectic combat experience
so puppets are all there are
I highly doubt that you'll have to face
all sorts of monsters puppets only being
one of them
you're not quite done yet bone chilling
bosses await you
if a boss seems too intimidating
you might want to get help from a
specter in Boss matches you can summon a
specter that will assist you in battle
with a bit of help you will be able to
defeat bosses with more use
the P organ is a system that allows you
to upgrade your character use quartz to
optimize P to your liking within the P
organ you can select which slots to
unlock depending on your preference
there will be times when you will be
confronted with choices where you can
give Comfort to others and sorrow or
despair by line or you can choose to
tell the truth
carve your own path
[Music]
foreign
Xbox
series and game pass coming to you this
September 19th
at the hearts of hellblade is our
ambition to sink you into cenova's world
and story to do this it's critical that
we make it as easy as possible for you
to suspend your disbelief one key method
of achieving this is our use of
performance capture
[Music]
what I want to achieve on stage is to
get the best performance and best
storytelling from the actors and then to
get that into the game as Faithfully as
possible I want to see what I saw on
stage in the game
watching it's time to find when we were
shooting the scene from the Xbox
showcase it was quite a a somber mood on
set because that was one of our moments
in the game where it's just senower just
Center and the Furies and we have an
opportunity to connect with the player
one-on-one
are they
where are you
married woman
at this point in Santa's Journey she's
had her confidence eroded there's a lot
of doubt
and she needs to find within herself
a spark of of hope that strength that
she has
in order to continue on everything I've
done
has led me to this place we've come so
far while the scene is relatively simple
the scale and complexity of our
performance capture has multiplied to
meet our creative Ambitions on hellblade
2.
we shot the first tailblade in the
boardroom of our old Studio it was very
MacGyver together in the new studio we
have a custom built mocap space which
has pretty much everything we could have
dreamed of we've got projectors so we
can recreate SATs on the ground if we
need to we've got loads of props that we
have available to us at any time so we
can build sets
[Music]
I remember coming into interview and
seeing the setup down there and
immediately being impressed by
a clear commitment that had been made to
underpinning great true to life
performance with great quality data so
we've got a lot more cameras this time
around
um they're kind of top of the line at
the moment and in the kind of space that
we have downstairs we have nearly
wall-to-wall coverage which is really
impressive and it's not something that
is common it's certainly a step up from
a few cameras set up in a boardroom with
our setup we can push even further on
our ambition of bringing through as much
of our actors performances as possible
into the game even down to the most
nuanced of movements
so when you've got a optical system like
ours set up and calibrated well you can
track performance movements down to the
millimeter so we can see somebody
shuffling their finger along the table
or just wiggling them very gently you
can see hesitation and breath there's no
need to push the action and overact you
can just be your character
I'm here now
what we want is the best performance
possible the best immersion possible for
the player and that's why we go to these
lengths just to try and get that extra
Fidelity of performance into the game
what do you want me to do
with performance capture being at the
heart of our character movement our
props and staging had to facilitate our
vision I don't want to give any spoilers
away but there is going to be a boat in
the game
that boy will have several characters on
board we wanted to be able to capture
the motion of a boat across multiple
characters simultaneously and we for the
first time had the space to be able to
to construct a proper rig for this so we
had a platform which could be moved in
any number of ways to create that kind
of pitch in your role that you would get
on the ocean and we got our actors up
onto this boat and captured scene with
highways and a storm and we've got
incredible data from really really
amazing
the most important part of my role is to
make sure that story gets told
and having these wonderful actors we're
working with
bring their talents to bear on these
characters has been such an amazing
experience
[Music]
my name is Larry herb Xbox's Major
Nelson welcome welcome to Fan Fest I'm
excited to be here here we go let's roll
that video
[Music]
report
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it's playing awesome games and having a
great time
there is so much going on here tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
honestly I've never felt so good to be
part of Xbox in my life I'm just
wandering around I've been talking to
people and everybody is so excited about
what's to come
[Music]
we really put a lot of emphasis on
empowering creative risk and then
there's so much excitement for what
we're going to be able to deliver going
into 2024 and even games in 2024 that we
haven't talked about yet so our mission
our strategy is to bring the joy of
gaming to everybody no matter where they
want to play how they want to play and I
just feel you know a real responsibility
a real privilege excitement that we get
to be the ones to build those games that
are going to be at the center of no
matter what we do
[Music]
hi I'm Sebastian and I'm the community
manager for light year Frontier today
I'll be playing with Kelly Anita and
Carolina to explore the new multiplayer
features like your Frontier has to offer
good morning good morning good morning
today we should continue building up the
base we started yesterday we'll need
more resources and it'll be faster if we
work together to collect them continue
work on that yeah let's go
[Music]
hey that purple neck looks great thanks
it's my favorite color
dang the part looks uh pretty good with
all the Drone crops yeah I know right
and I'm looking forward to making the
farm even bigger
I'm gonna work on uh making your home
look a little bit better and then I'll
uh I'll come down and help you out
great I'll see you in a bit then
hmm what do you want to focus on
Gathering you think
I can get wood to start with and then
you can help me get some aluminum
I'll get some Stone also then that
should cover a lot of what we need for
crafting and building
once we've finished let's head back and
help with the buildings we supply to the
rescues
how's it going up there
I think I've got a good idea of what I
want things to look like from up here
nice
oh there's so many good choices and all
right
uh but I think that looks good
oh wait see it there's loads of aluminum
here they're actually pretty strong so
we can do it faster if you're both
really let's work together and see what
else we can find here after we bring
this back I'll take a look in some other
regions to see what materials they have
I'm done up here so I'll come join you
my inventory is getting full from this
Harvest I think we should build some
like silos crates to store it all yeah
we should probably be able to fence
around those two as uh as well so we can
Protect the Harvest great idea let's get
on it here we go I'll help with the
silos next yo anyone need materials
because we got a ton of stuff yes please
oh my gosh fantastic
do you want this to start helping you
build
yes please please oh on it
what do you think of the layout
um yeah it looks great to me
I'm almost done with the fences here
hey everyone
ruins over there Max and come see this
oh wow what is this oh look at that this
is so cool that door is huge wow I
wonder what's inside though tomorrow we
should totally find a way to open this
let's head back to the base and see what
we can do
thank you
foreign
[Music]
kitty kitty go go let's look alive
my instructions
[Music]
welcome
foreign
[Music]
every year in our showcase there's one
game that kind of pops for me something
I'm very interested in this year we got
to announce 33 Immortals from Thunder
Lotus and I'm here now with Stefan and
will to walk through a demo of the game
which I've never played before first
time we have 33 people online incredibly
excited about this so we're going to
jump in all right okay let's stop
playing 33 Immortals is a co-op action
roguelike for 33 players you play a damn
Soul must rebel against God's final
judgment so there are three of us here
today on stage three upstairs and 27
people joining us from Montreal in the
studio hi everyone and we are ready
that's us everybody's spawning in that's
us
this is 33 player multiplayer yeah not a
normal number of characters for a
multiplayer game yeah how did you come
up with 33 players we were searching for
a significant number where we can all
play on the screen yeah we stay together
on the screen so 33 felt good 32 felt
good but as the game is inspired by the
Divine committee uh the medieval poem
from Dante Ali Jerry weekend in the 14th
century and this poem has three section
Inferno together
each section has 33 chapters and so we
say oh let's do 33
Immortals man I love what you said well
that when you guys started this game
there weren't even 33 people at the
studio so you didn't have enough people
in the studio to fill out the full
roster of the game yeah which is such an
awesome point it's a challenge it's a
challenge when you're trying to do that
I love it okay so no two runs are the
same we're actually spinning in a
different position a different situation
we are in the cemetery if you own the
left trigger so one map is going to show
up ah and we can see that we are 33
right now actually in Inferno which we
are scattered around the world oh we're
not all in the same place yeah yeah
because we all have to complete torture
chambers got it to make the game
progress okay and we are located at the
south west of Inferno yeah and so the
closest torture chambers is to the east
okay so let's go there got it
okay let's continue down sounds towards
the first third chambles
this one I have a good feeling for it
the uh soundtrack what's going on the
music's kind of cool oh thank you this
is uh Max LL who's actually done the
music on all of our games
and you're in Montreal we are in
Montreal yes close to one of our xgs
studios in compulsion yes it's also in
showcase yes I love the community of
game creators in Montreal absolutely
It's always important to be uh well
surrounded and all that so we didn't
talk about your first game Spirit prayer
yeah I loved I thought it was fantastic
thank you yeah it was great
now as you can see uh this is not Spirit
Fair
from a studio standpoint having such I
mean I would say they're stylized games
but yeah outside of that very different
games we're not worried about you know
genre our goal is really to just try and
make unique immersive creative
experiences that players love and that
they want to play for
awesome I love that yeah
this guy is
getting out of my comfort zone sometimes
oh all right what do we do so we have
completed a hotel chamber so we have
achieved the first step I got left
behind that's what you're saying oh God
yeah oh they're back on us ah whoa well
we gotta laugh of good careful oh no
[Music]
I
have like zero health
new torture no I gotta get out of here
where are you all right
well why weren't they in the torture
table trying to help us
okay these range uh good is getting
angrier yeah
wow we're getting hammered right now
come on okay here's a guy can you revive
me yeah yeah just stop moving come on up
yeah I'm up I'm up okay false thank you
[Music]
what is this
now we're in Holy Fire yeah the wrath of
God okay I'm ahead of it okay so we
unlocked the actions on Battle so that's
the last battle yes can people jump in
my heels yeah yeah yeah I mean I mean
a dragon video
don't mind me the wandering soul I
should save me please like a zombie
maybe someone that I mentioned I'd never
played before
I died too
okay hopefully the team the team can
carry us
there's a lot of enemies in this small
space I'm gonna try to not move okay
don't move and hopefully someone is
going to be able to revive you okay good
oh I met him up amen okay
okay I'm back yeah yeah thank you
so this is the last step I think it's my
life all right
okay yeah we did it that's yeah we did
it yeah well yeah we did it yeah yeah
so now we've ascended yeah that was
first chapter of first book Is that how
I should think about it yeah it's the
first world uh so it's Inferno yeah uh
and
um yeah each region has its whole big
set of challenges and everything and
this is all on the map and it's final
boss fight that's what this is well
since we've basically come through
unscathed so far this should be easy
you saved us from having to kill the
final boss
it's a bit of a tease ah I like it I
like it well best of luck to you and the
team and everything that's going on
can't wait for this game to come out I
won't ask for the date because I know
that's unfair but it was great to have
in the show and great for you to come
down and we got the opportunity to play
so thank you thank you so much thank you
so much for having us thanks for
watching showcase extended I love these
opportunities to show more about
everything that you saw in the in the
Showcase itself thanks to everybody that
supported us and have a great week
thanks everybody
[Music]
thank you